ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible] TEN
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLY.
DALY.
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ GRAY.
A SEND.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW MOAN [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MAYES MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
THE SYRIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS RAY YES.
THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
A QUORUM.
IS PRESENT.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVEREND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
A YOUNG MAN I'VE KNOWN SINCE HE
WAS FOUR YEARS OLD.
RECENTLY ASKED ME.
HOW CAN I BE HAPPY?
IT'S A QUESTION WE PROBABLY HAVE
ALL QUIETLY ASKED OURSELVES FROM
TIME TO TIME. FOR EVERYONE SEEKS
HAPPINESS.
WE WOULD ALL LIKE TO FEEL
CONTENT IN FEEL THAT OUR LIVES
ARE COMPLETE.
IF THERE IS THE SECRET TO
HAPPINESS IT IS WHEN WE DISCOVER
THAT ARE REAL HAPPINESS EMERGES
NATURALLY.
WHEN WE BECOME ON CENTERED ON
OURSELVES?
THINK ABOUT THE TIMES YOU WENT
TO A CHIU THE GREAT MOVIE PLAYER
CONCERT.
WE LEFT THE EVENT SMILING SAYING
THINGS LIKE THAT WAS GREAT I
ENJOYED THAT SO MUCH.
MAYBE EVEN TELLING FRIENDS I'D
LIKE TO SEE THAT AGAIN.
WHY WAS IT SUCH A GREAT TIME?
WHY WERE WE FEELING SO HAPPY?
THE REASON IS SIMPLE. FOR THE
DURATION OF THE ENTIRE MOVIE
PLAY OR CONCERT WE WERE TOTALLY
UNKNOWN CENTERED ON OURSELVES.
WE WERE NOT THINKING HOW DO I
FEEL AM I HAPPY.
WE'RE NOT JUDGING WHAT IS GOOD
OR BAD RIGHT OR WRONG.
INSTEAD WE LET GO OF OUR
CRITICAL MINDS AND BECOME ONE
WITH THE EXPERIENCE.
WE BECOME ON CENTERED ON
OURSELVES IN THE FEELING OF
HAPPINESS NATURALLY EMERGES.
EVERY CHIU SPIRITUAL TRADITION
RECOGNIZES THIS REALITY AND IS
TRY TO SHARE THIS AWARENESS IN
SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
THE PERSIAN SPIRITUAL POET RUMI
BEAUTIFULLY SHARED.
BEYOND RIGHT AND WRONG.
THERE IS A FIELD.
I WILL MEET YOU THERE.
HE WAS SAYING BEYOND OUR
JUDGEMENTS OF GOOD AND BAD MINE
AND YOURS SELF AND OTHERS.
THERE IS A PLACE.
A PLACE WHERE WE ARE NO LONGER
CENTERED ON OURSELVES.
IT IS A PLACE WHERE WE SENSE THE
ONENESS OF ALL HUMANITY.
I WILL MEET YOU THERE.
NOW MORE ME THEM.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE
JOIN ME IN HONORING OUR COUNTRY
BY PLEDGING TO THE FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
AND MISSION -- IS A LITTLE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MAY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN THE
ASSEMBLY MET AT NINE AM ON OVER
BACK UP OUR QUE HAN ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE SILLY
PRESIDING CHIEF CURRY E. DOCKS
MISTER CALDERON MOVES.
AND MR FLORA SECONDS THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FILL TANK. FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN
COOLEY.
AND FOR A FUNERAL A DEATH IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION SIR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MOVE SUS TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO WITHDRAW AB THREE
NINETY TWO WEBER FROM THE RULES
COMMITTEE IN ORDER TO BUILD THE
THIRD READING FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE REQUEST.
I HAVE A BIG.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE REQUEST IS
GRANTED THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SEVEN I MOVED TO RE REFER ITEM
FOURTEEN AB THIRTY SIXTEEN
GALLAGHER TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION [inaudible]
MR FLORA.
WE OBJECT AS FOR ROLL CALL MR
FLORA IS OBJECTING IN THIS CASE
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
BONTA SECONDS.
ON THE MOTION TO RE REFER.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO
MISTER CALDERON TO ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
AND MISTER FLORES ASKING.
FOR A NO VOTE ON THE MOTION
REFER TAKES.
FORTY ONE CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL
EYES FORTY FIVE KNOWS.
FOURTEEN MOTION REFER CARRIES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
MEMBERS MAY HAVE ATTENTION.
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER.
WE WELCOME LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS FROM AROUND THE STATE.
ON THE OCCASION OF PEACE
OFFICERS DAY AT THE CAPITOL THEY
ARE SEATED IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
WELCOME THEM ALL TO THE ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS ADDITIONALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS WE WELCOME
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS FROM
HER DISTRICT IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY.
AS WELL AS YOUR SPOUSE FRANK RAY
YES THEY ARE ALL SEATED IN THE
GALLERY WELCOME THEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS ON RECONSIDERATION ITEM
NUMBER ONE PASS.
AND WE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE ITEM
TO BE.
CONTINUED.
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEMS
TWO AND THREE PASS RETAIN.
MR HOLDEN IF YOU ARE READY TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
THIS IS AB.
TWENTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
A SOMETHING ALL TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE HIGHWAYS.
THIS HOLDING EMAIL BUT I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY NINE A SOLUTION TO A
PROBLEM.
THAT HAS BEEN DIVIDE IN THE SAN
GABRIEL FOR TOO LONG THE BILL
REMOVES THAT MOST DISPUTED LAND
OF THE S. R. SEVEN TEN FROM THE
FREEWAY AND EXPRESSWAY CODE.
A LINE IN THE LAW WITH THE
DESIRES OF THE CITIES AND THE
FINALIZED CALTRANS THE IR.
IT ALSO ESTABLISHES A PROCESS
THAT REQUIRES CALTRANS IN METRO
TO CONSULT THE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES AND GET AGREEMENT
FROM THEM BEFORE CONSTRUCTING
NEW PROJECTS.
LAST YEAR ELEMENTARY CALTRANS TO
CLEAR THE LOCALLY PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE TO BE TRAFFIC DEMAND
MATTERS BUT NOT A FREEWAY.
I'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSION WITH ALL
THE COMMUNITIES AND INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE IMPACTED TO ENSURE THIS
BILL INCORPORATES FEEDBACK FROM
THE MALL.
I WILL CONTINUE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS TO MAKE SURE WE GET
THIS PROJECT RIGHT.
THIS BILL WILL ALIGN THEM.
TO ALLOW THEM TO IMPROVE TRAFFIC
FLOW.
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING GRAY
GREEN SPACES.
CREATE BIKE LANES AND DEDICATED
BUS ROUTES INSTEAD OF CROWDED
STREETS BUILD MIXED USE SPACES
FOR RETAIL HOUSING AND
ENTERTAINMENT.
AND WHATEVER ELSE THESE
COMMUNITIES CAN COME UP WITH.
WE'RE AT A TIPPING POINT WITH
THE SIXTY YOUR PROJECT AND ASK.
YOU TO HELP US GET IT OVER THE
FINISH LINE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TELEVOTE.
ICE.
FORTY FOUR NO.
SIX THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS AB
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN CORKERY.
A SOME OF ELEVEN EIGHTEEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
AND ACTUALLY THE LAND USE THIS
RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN THE H. FRIENDLY
ACT.
THIS BILL AIMS TO ADDRESS LIVE
ABILITY ISSUES FOR SENIORS AND
RECEIPT RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK WAS RUBIO SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OR CLUB IN THE ROLE -- MEMBERS.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL.
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
SIX KNOWS.
NINE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN AB SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY TO FIREARMS MR BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY
NINE PROMOTES GREATER PUBLIC
SAFETY.
AND A MORE COMPREHENSIVE POLICY
ENFORCEMENT MODEL FOR
INDEPENDENT AMMUNITION VENDORS
AT CALIFORNIA GUN SHOWS CURRENT
LAW OUTLINES PUBLIC SAFETY
MEASURES FOR FIRE ARMS DEALERS
WHO SELL AMMUNITION A GUN SHOWS
IN THE STATE.
BUT INDEPENDENT AMMUNITION
VENDORS DO NOT RECEIVE THE SAME
SCRUTINY AB SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE
WOULD CORRECT THIS DISCREPANCY
BY REQUIRING INDEPENDENT
AMMUNITION VENDORS TO BE
LICENSED VENDORS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO CHARGE A FEE OF
THIRTEEN DOLLARS IN NINETEEN
CENTS PER FIRE ARMS RELATED
TRANSACTION.
SOLELY TO COVER THE COST OF ITS
FIRE ARMS RELATED REGULATORY AND
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSIBILITIES.
COLLEAGUES THERE ARE OVER ONE
HUNDRED GUN SHOWS IN CALIFORNIA
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENFORCING FIREARMS LAWS AT THESE
GUN SHOWS.
A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE ENSURES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO PERFORM
THE DUTIES TO KEEP THE PUBLIC
SAFE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK MISS BONTA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE START OF IT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
TAKES FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
[inaudible]
ROSARIO
.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FORTY THREE
KNOWS.
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM.
EIGHT ASCERTAIN THAT BRINGS US
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINE AB SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN BY MS
RUBIO CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN BY SOMETHING
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AND ACTUALLY
THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
THIS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
FOURTEEN HERE TODAY.
DURING MY TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE I HAVE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF SERVING ON THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SOMEONE
COMMITTEE RELATING TO HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
THROUGH THROUGH THESE HEARINGS I
ALONG WITH MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND THEIR ABILITY
TO DELIVER SERVICES IN A
RESPONSIBLE MANNER.
DH CS HAS A TOTAL BUDGET
PROJECTED TO BE JUST ABOUT A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY INCLUDING ALL STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDS.
GIVING THE DHC HAS THE LARGEST
DEPARTMENT MENTAL BUDGET IN THE
STATE.
THIS BILL AB SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN
WILL BEGIN A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION ON HOW TO BEST
IMPROVE DIS H. C. S. AND
INCREASED PERFORMANCE STANDARDS.
I PLAN ON WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BILL BRINGS INCREASED
ACCOUNTABILITY. TO THE
DEPARTMENT BY INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY.
THE BILL THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
A NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE ICE [inaudible]
FIFTY NINE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN IS AB.
SEVENTEEN TEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AND
ACTUALLY TO CANNABIS.
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
IN NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
VOTERS APPROVED PROP SIXTY FOUR
WHICH LEGALIZED OF PURCHASING
CONSUMPTION OF RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS.
UNDER MEDICINAL AT A AND A DON'T
USE CANNABIS REGULATIVE
REGULATES REGULATION AND SAFETY
ACT THAT'S A MOUTHFUL.
OF THE LICENSING AND REGULATION
OF CANNABIS ACTIVITIES IS
SUBJECT TO LOCAL AUTHORIZATION
BEFORE A LICENSING AUTHORITY MAY
PROVE A STATE AT LICENSE
APPLICATION.
THERE'S CLEARLY GREAT
UNCERTAINTY INTO HOW AN
APPLICANT ON TRIBAL LAND RECEIVE
LOCAL AUTHORIZATION FOR A STATE
LICENSE WITHOUT AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
A TRIBE.
AS A RESULT OF THE SENSOR
UNCERTAINTY AND TO HOW AN
APPLICANT ON TRIBAL LAND WOULD
RECEIVE LOCAL OF AUTHORIZATION
WITHOUT AGREEMENT WITH BETWEEN
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND A TRIBE
THE COUNTY OF DON'T NOR IN THE
ELK VALLEY RANCHERIA ENTERED
INTO A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING.
REGARDING THE TAXATION AND
REGULATION OF CANNABIS
CULTIVATION OPERATION INSIDE THE
OP ALLEY RANCHERIA.
AB TWENTY A. B..
THE SIX FORTY ONE THAT'S NOT THE
RIGHT NUMBER.
AB SEVENTEEN TEN SEES ME IS A
NARROW BILL WHICH WOULD SIMPLE
HAS SIMPLY CODIFIED THE MO YOU
BETWEEN THE OP ALLEY RANCHERIA
AND THE COUNTY OF DAHLE NORT.
ESTABLISHED LOCAL I.
AUTHORIZATION FOR CANNABIS
RELATED ACTIVITY ON THE L.
FAMILY RANCHERIA ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
LICENSEE TO COMPLY WITH ALL
REQUIREMENTS OF CURRENT LAW.
INCLUDING AMONG OTHER THINGS
COMPLY WITH ALL SEEK WORK
REQUIREMENTS COLLECTON REMISS
REMITTANCE OF STATE TAXES AND
COMPLIANCE AUDITS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WHAT.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF USER TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF CLERK WILL
[inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY SEVEN
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN IS AB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE BY MISTER BLOOM.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE BY SOMETHING MEMBER BLOOM
AND ACTUALLY THE RESIDENTIAL
REAL PROPERTY.
THE SHOVEL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE ELLIS ACT
WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE AND WAS INTENDED AS A MEANS
FOR LANDLORDS TO EXIT THE RENTAL
HOUSING BUSINESS.
BUT NOT AS AN END RUN AROUND
LOCAL PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS --
AND UNFORTUNATELY A LIMITED
NUMBER OF LAND YOU LORDS HAVE
IMPROPERLY USE THE LAW TO DO
JUST THAT.
SO THIS BILL MAKES CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO THE ELLIS ACT THAT
ARE INTENDED TO BOTH ENSURE
FAIRNESS FOR TENANTS.
AND REMOVE AMBIGUITY FOR BOTH
LANDLORDS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
SOME MY LANDLORDS HAVE BEEN
EVICTING TENANTS UNDER THE GUISE
OF EXITING THE RENTAL HOUSING
BUSINESS BUT ACTUALLY HAVING NO
INTENT TO ACTUALLY LEAVE THE
MARKET SO INSTEAD THEY'VE GAME
THE SYSTEM.
TO AVOID.
LOCAL PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS
AND TO ADDRESS THESE ABUSES AB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE WILL
CLARIFY THE ELLIS ACT IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS.
FIRST WHEN A LANDLORD WITHDRAWS
A BUILDING UNDER THE ALSO ACT.
I IT WILL BE -- CLARIFIED THAT
THERE IS ONLY ONE WITHDRAWAL
DATE AND ONE DATE FOR RETURNING
THE UNITS TO THE RENTAL MARKET.
A LANDLORD WILL NO LONGER BE
ALLOWED TO PICK AND CHOOSE WHICH
UNITS TO RETURN IN WHICH TO NOT.
SECOND.
THE BILL PROVIDES AN EXCEPTION
TO THE ABOVE FOR UNITS THAT ARE
OWNER OCCUPIED AT THE TIME OF
WITHDRAWAL A PROTECTION FOR
LANDLORDS.
THIRD THE LAW WILL MAKE CLEAR
THAT THE PAYMENT OF A PENALTY
DOES NOT EXTINGUISH THE
LANDLORDS OBLIGATION TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW.
AND FINALLY IT WILL CLARIFY THAT
IF A LANDLORD ALLOWS A TENANT
WHO NEEDS MORE TIME TO MOVE TO
STAY BEYOND THE END OF THE
TERMINATION NOTICE.
THAT A VOLUNTARY ACTION BY THE
LANDLORD DOES NOT EXTEND THE
TIME LINE UNDER THAT ACT.
WELL I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT WE
HAVE REACHED AN AGREEMENT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE REALTORS AND
OTHER INDUSTRY GROUPS THAT HAVE
REMAINED.
THAT A REMOVED ALL REMAINING
CONCERNS AND WE'LL BE TAKING
THESE ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE.
THIS BILL GIVES TENANTS SOME
SECURITY IN KEEPING THEIR HOMES
IN A TIME WHEN HOMELESSNESS FOR
OUR POOR SENIORS DISABLED AND
EVEN WORKING CLASS.
INDIVIDUALS IS A REALITY THAT'S
JUST A PAYCHECK OR RENT INCREASE
THE WAY TO THE LACK OF READILY
AVAILABLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM [inaudible]
QUIRK LIBERAL.
RESERVE AT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE DOUBLE [inaudible] ONE THIS
TAKES.
FORTY ONE YEAH
.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE AND TELL
IT ABOUT ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS TWELVE THROUGH
FOURTEEN PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN IS AB FIVE
TWENTY THREE BY MISS OR WHEN.
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY THREE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
MR WHEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB.
FIVE TWO THREE THIS BILL IS IN
RESPONSE TO TROUBLING
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISM THAT
UNCOVERED THE PRACTICE OF
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES
SELLING SENSITIVE SUBSCRIBER
DATA MOST CONCERNING REAL TIME
GEO LOCATION DATA.
WITH AB FIVE TWO THREE
CALIFORNIA'S WILL BE ABLE TO
HOLD TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES
TO THEIR WORD AND NOT HAVE TO
WAIT FOR THE FCC TO DECIDE TO DO
THEIR JOB.
AND PROTECTS CELL PHONE LOCATION
PRIVACY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I'VE A THANK YOU MISTER ONE
SCENE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AN ICE FIFTY
ONE KNOWS A THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN IS AB TWO
TWENTY BY MR BONTA.
CLICK WITH A SOME ABLE TO TWENTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR MR BONTA EMAIL WITH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. TWO TWENTY IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL.
THAT REMOVES BARRIERS TO ANYONE
SEEKING TO SERVE IN ELECTED
OFFICE BY ALLOWING ANY CANDIDATE
TO USE THEIR CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR
CHILD CARE EXPENSES INCURRED AS
A RESULT OF CAMPAIGNING.
THIS BILL WILL HELP PARENTS WITH
YOUNG CHILDREN SERVE IN PUBLIC
OFFICE IT WILL ALSO HELP TO
ADVANCE MUCH NEEDED GENDER
PARITY AMONG OUR ELECTED.
OFFICIALS CURRENTLY WOMEN
COMPRISE 30% OF THE LEGISLATURE
THAT'S ACTUALLY GROWTH OVER LAST
SESSIONS TOTAL OF 22%.
BUT IT'S CLEAR THESE NUMBERS
STILL FALL FAR SHORT OF GENDER
PARITY YOUNG PARENTS BRING AN
IMPORTANT VOICE THE POLICY
DEBATES THEIR VOICES WE NEED TO
HEAR MORE.
NOT LESS ANYONE WHO CURRENTLY
TRIES TO USE CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR
CHILDCARE FACES RISK AND
UNCERTAINTY THEY WOULD BE
RELYING ON A TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD INFORMAL ADVICE LETTER.
BY THE F. B. B. C. THIS BILL
WILL OFFER EVERYONE WHO WANTS TO
SEEK AND SERVE IN PUBLIC OFFICE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO CAMPAIGN
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER THEY WILL RUN AFOUL OF
OUR STATES COMPLICATED AND IN
THIS REGARD CERTAIN CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAWS THIS BIPARTISAN
BILL.
HAS RECEIVE NO NO VOTES THUS FAR
SUPPORTED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU RESPOND TO MISS ROW
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
AS A CO AUTHOR WE ACTUALLY
INTRODUCE THE SAME BILL THE
SESSION SO WE THOUGHT WE'D WORK
TOGETHER -- IN MAY OF LAST YEAR
THE FCC RULED THAT CANDIDATES
FOR CONGRESS COULD USE FUNDS FOR
CHILDCARE.
CALIFORNIAN LONG PERMITTED THIS
PRACTICE HOWEVER IT NEEDED TO BE
CODIFIED. TO EXPOSE WE PERMIT.
SPENDING CAMPAIGN FUNDS ON
CHILDCARE THIS IN TURN WILL
RELIEVE A CANDIDATES NEED TO ASK
PERMISSION INDIVIDUALLY AND DRAW
SCRUTINY TO THEIR CAMPAIGNS
WHILE THE COST OF CHILDCARE
ASSISTED SUBSTANTIAL -- ONE TOO
MANY PEOPLE IF NOT ALL
CALIFORNIANS RAISING A FAMILY --
THIS BILL IS ABOUT ANYBODY WHO
WANTS TO RUN FOR OFFICE THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO PICK UP THEIR
CHILDREN OVER RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
AND MANY TIMES I'D LIKE MY WIFE
TO ATTEND EVENTS WITH ME BUT WE
HAVE TO DIVIDE AND CONQUER SO AS
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISS ROW THIS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
AS A MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN I
KNOW HOW HARD IT IS -- WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
TRYING TO NAVIGATE THE LONG
HOURS -- THAT ARE SPENT AWAY
FROM YOUR CHILDREN AND JUST TO
BE CLEAR AND I STAYED AT THIS --
AND COMMITTEE THIS THE
GRANDPARENTS ARE NOT INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL THERE IT IT'S OUR
OBLIGATION TO TAKE CARE OF
CHILDREN -- BUT THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY -- FOR TO CHILD
CARE THAT.
CANDIDATES HAVE TO SPEND.
MONEY ON BECAUSE OF THE SPECIFIC
CAMPAIGN RELATED ACTIVITIES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO MR GALLAGHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
SO WE HAD THIS BILL IN THE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
AND I I UNDERSTAND WHERE.
THE AUTHOR IN THE SUPPORTERS OF
THIS BILL ARE COMING FROM
CERTAINLY I UNDERSTAND IT VERY
WELL HAVING FIVE CHILDREN OF MY
OWN.
AND UNDERSTAND THE DIFFICULTY.
OF OF DOING DOING THIS WORK AND
STILL.
YOUR TRYING TO BE THERE AND AND
HAVE CHILD CARE FOR YOUR
CHILDREN -- I'LL MY WIFE --
LIKES TO COME TO A BENCH WITH ME
AS WELL AND SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT YOU KNOW HOW TO DO THOSE
THINGS -- BUT WE'RE RIGHT WHERE
I KIND OF FEEL THIS IS IS
SOMEWHAT MISGUIDED AND STILL
NEEDS.
A LOT OF WORK IS FIRST OF ALL
THINK ABOUT.
ALL THE OTHER.
YOUR REGULAR CITIZENS OUT THERE
THEY HAVE TO FIGURE THIS OUT TO
AND IF THEY DON'T QUALIFY FOR A
PROGRAM.
THEY DON'T GET ANYBODY TO
SUBSIDIZE THEIR CHILD CARE THEY
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO PAY
THOSE COSTS.
MANY OF OUR OWN STAFF WHO WORK
IN THIS BUILDING.
DON'T THEY MAKE TOO MUCH TO
QUALIFY FOR ANY PROGRAMS.
AND NOT ENOUGH IN MANY CASES TO
PAY FOR A LOT OF CHILD CARE.
SO WHY ARE TO ME THIS BILL IS IN
SOME WAYS MAKING AN EXCEPTION
FOR US.
JUST FOR THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE ACCOUNTS -- TO
ALLOW THIS TO BE USED TO THE WE
CAN HELP PAY FOR THAT. TO ME.
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT MISGUIDED
SPECIAL MORE TALKING ABOUT IN
THIS CHAMBER THIS YEAR.
ABOUT THE HIGH COST OF CHILDCARE
IN ABOUT A TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
MORE MORE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS --
I THINK.
YOU KNOW TRYING TO DO THIS NOW
IN AND SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
MORE HELPING US THAT IT IS
NECESSARILY HELPING.
OTHERS WHO FACE THIS ISSUE WE
ALL HAVE THIS IS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY FACES
HIS APPARENT.
AND WHO AND WHO.
DOES THESE JOBS AND THEY WHO HAS
TO GO OUT INTO THE WORK FORCE
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE GOING TO
PAY FOR THAT -- THE OTHER
PROBLEM I HAVE WITH THIS BILL
AND I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ONE TO AND AND SHOULD BE THE
CAUSE FOR AN AMENDMENT.
IS WE'RE SAYING THIS IS FOR
CAMPAIGN RELATED ACTIVITIES AND
USUALLY.
THINGS THAT ARE RELATED TO
CAMPAIGNING ARE.
ALLOWED TO BE COVERED BY OUR
CAMPAIGN FUNDS IN OUR CAMPAIGN
ACCOUNTS -- AND I COULD SEE HOW
REALISTICALLY.
GOING TO AN EVENT GOING OUT
CAMPAIGNING -- MAKING SPEECHES
THERE MAY BE A TIME WHEN YOU
NEED TO HAVE CHILD CARE AND THEN.
THAT WOULD BE PART OF A
LEGITIMATE CAMPAIGN EXPENSE BUT
WHAT THIS ALSO HAS IN HERE IS
ALSO IN YOUR OFFICIAL DUTIES.
AS AN OFFICE HOLDER.
WELL THAT COULD COVER A WHOLE
HOST OF THINGS THAT AREN'T
NECESSARILY CAMPAIGN RELATED.
THEY'RE JUST DOING THIS JOB.
WELL EVERYBODY ELSE OUT THERE IN
THE REAL WORLD HAS A JOB THAT
THEY HAVE TO DO.
TO AND I DON'T THINK THAT WORRY
ARE MORE SPECIAL.
AS I SAID.
THEN EVERYBODY ELSE.
AND SO TO BE ABLE TO USE
CAMPAIGN.
FUNDS FOR SOMETHING THAT.
IS REALLY A WORK RELATED
ACTIVITY NOT NECESSARILY A
CAMPAIGN.
RELATED ACTIVITY IS A IS A BIG
GRAY AREA.
AND AGAIN I THINK IT IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A YOU KNOW.
A LITTLE BIT TONE DEAF -- IN
THIS THERE WERE MANY PEOPLE ARE
HAVING TO MAKE THESE TOUGH
DECISIONS.
AND WE'RE SORT OF PROVIDING OUR
OWN SELF.
A WAY TO SUBSIDIZE THAT.
SO I YOU KNOW THIS POINT I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANKS GALLAGHER MISS POWER QUE
HAN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE. TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH.
I AM A MOTHER OF THREE KIDS AND
ALTHOUGH MY SPOUSE COMING WITH
ME IS IMPORTANT I THINK THAT ONE
OF US NEEDS TO RISE TODAY AND
SPEAK FOR THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE SPOUSES.
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED TO RUN FOR
OFFICE AND DON'T HAVE THAT
SUPPORT NETWORK AT HOME THIS
BODY SHOULD BE A REFLECTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
AMAZING WOMEN AND MEN IN IT WHO
ARE RAISING CHILDREN ON THEIR
OWN.
AND WE NEED TO WORK TO GET THOSE
PEOPLE SITTING AT THESE TASKS IN
VOTING ON THE THINGS THAT MATTER
TO EVERY CALIFORNIAN AND THIS IS
A SMALL STEP IN MAKING SURE
THOSE PEOPLE CAN RUN FOR OFFICE.
THEY CAN REPRESENT THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AND THEY CAN HAVE A
VOICE IN THE ISSUES THAT WE VOTE
ON DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
AND SO I AM PROUD TO CO AUTHOR
THIS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND
I ASK THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK
TO MAKE THIS BODY MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK WAS BAR CAM MS GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE BUT WHEN I ACTUALLY
RAN FOR OFFICE I WAS A SINGLE
MOM WITH YOUNG KIDS.
AND I MY KIDS WENT EVERYWHERE
WITH ME LARGELY BECAUSE THAT WAS
THE ONLY OPTION I HAD.
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO HAVE TRUE
DIVERSITY IN ON THIS FLOOR. TO
DIVERSITY GOES BEYOND GENDER AND
RACE IT GOES TO LIFE
CIRCUMSTANCE AND I THINK THE
FACT THAT I WAS A SINGLE MOM
MAKES ME A BETTER LEGISLATOR I
THINK IT MADE IT.
ENSURES THAT I AM MORE AWARE OF
THE TYPE OF PEOPLE WERE WORRIED
ABOUT OFFENDING A SUPPOSEDLY --
THAT THAT DON'T HAVE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES I AM CONFIDENT
THAT YOU COULD ASK ANY.
WORKING FAMILY WORKING SINGLE
MOM ESPECIALLY MY DISTRICT OF
WHETHER OR NOT I SHOULD BE ABLE
TO USE CAMPAIGN FUNDS TO PAY FOR
CHILD CARE AND THEY SAY
ABSOLUTELY.
AND BY THE WAY THE THING THAT'S
A LITTLE OFF IS WE COULD
ACTUALLY USE CAMPAIGN FUNDS TO
PAY FOR CHILDCARE OVERALL AT AN
EVENT. TO SERVE OTHER PEOPLE'S
KIDS OUR OWN STAFF KIDS BUT NOT
FOR OURSELVES WITHOUT SOME
CLARITY.
IT WE'RE NOT LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE
IF I HAVE A FRIEND WHO OWNS A
CHILD CARE FACILITY THEY SAID
THAT'S OKAY LEAVE YOUR KIDS WITH
ME.
FEW NIGHTS A WEEK AND IT IT IT'S
NO PROBLEM THAT IS A PROBLEM
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
TAKE THAT GIFT.
SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S TRUE
DIVERSEY ON THIS FLOOR THAT INTO
CLUES DIVERSITY OF CLASS AND
CIRCUMSTANCE.
AND I'D SAY THAT THIS IS ONE
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I'M
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MS CONSOLES MISS
MELENDEZ.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
LEASING GENTLEMAN I I'M A PARENT
TO LIKE MANY OF YOU IN HERE I
HAVE FIVE KIDS MYSELF WHEN I RAN
FOR OFFICE MY KIDS WERE ALL.
FAIRLY YOUNG AND WE DID NOT --
WE MADE IT WORK AND I REALIZE
THAT NOT EVERYONE CAN DO THAT
ARE RUNNING FOR OFFICE IS A
CHOICE.
IT'S VOLUNTARY NOBODY HAS TO RUN
PROP ISSUE NOT DRAFTED INTO THE
POSITION.
AND SO YOU HAVE TO MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS LIKE YOU WOULD ANY
OTHER JOB. TO MAKE ARRANGEMENTS
FOR CHILD CARE.
AND THOUGH IT'S NOT TAXPAYER
MONEY IS COMING FROM DONORS -- I
JUST I I DON'T SEE THIS AS AN
APPROPRIATE -- EXPENSE I THINK
IT MAKES US LOOK ELITIST I THINK
IT MAKES US LOOK LIKE WE'RE
PRIMA DONNAS BECAUSE WE THINK
THAT WE DESERVE. TO HAVE SPECIAL
TREATMENT IS SPECIAL CHILD CARE
AND HAVE THAT FUNDED BY SOMEONE
OTHER THAN OURSELVES.
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU THINK OF
ALL THE OTHER PEOPLE OUT THERE
WHO ARE TRYING TO PAY THEIR
CHILD CARE BILLS YOU DON'T HAVE
A SEPARATE ACCOUNT OF DONORS
THAT THEY CAN USE. TO PAY -- FOR
THAT CHILD CARE SO RESPECTFULLY
THOUGH I I APPRECIATE WHAT THE
AUTHORS ARE -- TRYING TO DO.
I I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANKS.
THANK YOU MS ONE THIS IS BURKE
YOUR RECOGNIZE -- I'D LIKE TO
FIRST I LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR
I'D LIKE TO THINK MY COLLEAGUES
THAT SPOKE ABOUT SINGLE MOTHERS
HERE ON THIS FLOOR.
AS A SINGLE MOTHER TODAY AS I
CAME TO THIS FLOOR MY DAUGHTER
WAS BORN BETWEEN MY GENERAL MY
PRIMARY.
I WASN'T SINGLE AND SO I KNOW
BOTH SIDES OF THIS COIN.
I KNOW HOW CHALLENGING THIS
PLACE HAS BEEN AS I HAVE BECOME
SINGLE AND WHETHER THAT WAS ME
HAVING TO GO BUY A CAR SO THAT I
COULD PARTICIPATE HERE OR IT IS
ABOUT MY DAUGHTER BEING ALLOWED
TO BE IN THIS SPACE.
I LOVE BEING A LEGISLATOR I AM
GOOD AT IT AND YOU'RE RIGHT IT
IS MY CHOICE.
IT'S MY CHOICE TO BE HERE.
BUT IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
DIVERSITY IS A PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS FLOOR THEN WE MUST BE ABLE
TO AS PARTICIPANTS HERE SUPPORT
EACH OTHER.
AND ONE OF THE WAYS WE DO THAT
IS BY VOTING FOR THINGS LIKE
THIS.
TONE DEAF I DON'T THINK THIS IS
TONE DEAF.
I DON'T THINK THIS MEASURES TONE
DEAF AND ANYWAY.
I THINK OF THOSE WHO BELIEVE
THAT SINGLE MOTHERS DON'T FACE
CHALLENGE ARE TONE DEAF.
THOSE WHO BELIEVE THAT SINGLE
MOTHERS DON'T BELONG HERE ARE
TONE DEAF.
WE FACE A SEPARATE SET OF
CHALLENGES AND MY COLLEAGUES ARE
RIGHT.
IT MAKES US BETTER LEGISLATORS
IT REMINDS US WHEN WE VOTE ON
THE BILL'S LIKE WE DID LAST WEEK --
LIKE TO VOTE ON THE BILL'S LIKE
WE WILL THIS WEEK.
WE HAVE AN EXPERIENCE THAT WE
CAN BRING TO THOSE VOTES.
I HAVE FACE THE CHALLENGES ON
THIS FLOOR FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS AS A SINGLE MOTHER
[inaudible]
I APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE
EVERY TIME THAT I GET SOMEBODY
WHO UNDERSTANDS WHAT IT IS LIKE
TO BE AWAY FROM MY DAUGHTER THIS
ISN'T A NORMAL JOB.
MONDAYS THROUGH THURSDAYS I AM
TAKEN AWAY FROM MY HOME.
LAST YEAR WE HAD TO PASS A BILL
SO THAT MY CHILD COULD BE HERE
WITH ME AND GO TO SCHOOL HERE
WITH ME WE ARE -- BALDING AS A
BODY AND THIS IS JUST PART OF
THAT EVOLUTION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS BURKE MISTER COOPER
DIRECTION MISTER SPEAKER I DON'T
HAVE A DOG IN THIS FIGHT MY KIDS
ARE ALL GROWN.
THE FOR THE LA MEMBERS THAT FLAP
HERE MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY
YOU'RE MISSING A LOT MY HOUSE IS
TWELVE MINUTES FROM THE BUILDING
THE TRAFFIC-- I CLOSE MY
DOLLARS IN BASEBALL SOFTBALL AND
SOCCER I WAS THERE ALL THE TIME
YOUR HOME ON THE WEEKENDS IN THE
BAY AREA FOLKS.
YOUR RUN AROUND FOR YOUR
DISTRICT.
YOUR DISTRICT ELECTION.
SO YEAH IF YOU'RE DOING THINGS
THAT YOU SHOULD GET. TO BELIEVE
THAT MONEY I UNDERSTAND I GET IT
SO IT'S JUST ONE OF THOSE THINGS
YEAH YOU ALL ASK FOR WE ASK FOR
IT BUT WE DO A LOT THIS JOB
INVOLVED A LOT OF THINGS A LOT
OF MOVING PARTS.
NOT JUST SACRAMENTO IT'S IT'S
IT'S VERY HARD WORKING ON
FAMILIES ESPECIALLY YOU WE'VE A
LOT OF FOLKS NOW WITH LITTLE
KIDS AND THAT'S TOUGH I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU DO IT.
I DON'T YOU I I RESPECT FOR YOU.
MS RESPECT I KNOW HOW YOU DO IT
BUT THIS IS A SMALL PIECE TO USE
THAT.
A FOR THOSE FOLKS IN THE LATE
WE'RE EVOLVING WE'RE CHANGING.
YOU KNOW MORE PARENTS MORE WOMEN
HERE.
DIFFERENT TIMES IT'S OKAY TO
CHANGE THINGS.
SO I COMMEND YOU LIKE I SAID IT
GOES BACK -- TO DOING ALL THE
GOOD WORK FOR THE STATE.
AND THIS IS A SMALL SIMPLE THING
TO HELP YOU IN YOUR DAILY LIFE
SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER MISTER
VALLEY YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL -- IT'S NOT TAXPAYERS
MONEY FIRST OF ALL IT'S YOUR
DONORS MONEY [inaudible]
AND THEY I WILL CHOOSE NOT TO
DONATE TO YOU THEY THINK YOU'RE
INAPPROPRIATELY.
USING YOUR FANS WE US YES WE
HAVE LAWS.
THAT SAY HOW WE CAN AND CAN'T
USE OUR CAMPAIGN FINANCES BUT I
STAND I'M FOUR AND A HALF HOURS.
THE ONLY WAY I CAN GET HOMES BY
DRIVING.
AND IF THERE WAS A SINGLE MOM
AND MY DISTRICT YOU WANTED TO
RUN AND YOU TO CHILD SECURE CARE
TO SERVE ON THIS FLOOR.
I THINK IT'S PROPER THAT WE BE
ABLE TO USE THOSE RESOURCES TO
HELP HER.
OR THAT FAMILY I DON'T HAVE FIVE
KIDS I GOT -- THREE BUT MY
CHILDREN WERE ALSO SMALL WHEN I
STARTED IN -- I MISSED A LOT OF
THINGS AND I TRY TO GET THEM
HERE AND I'M FORTUNATE TO HAVE.
THE OPPORTUNITY HAVE A AWESOME
WIFE THAT CANNOT COME ALONGSIDE
ME SO I STAND WITH THE SINGLE
MOMS ON THIS FLOOR.
AND THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO MAKE
IT WORK I THINK IT BALANCES OUT
OUR LEGISLATURE IN A STRONG WAY
AND I REGION I VOTE ON AB.
TWO TWENTY THANK YOU MISTER
DALLI MISTER PATTERSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT TO APPRECIATE
THAT.
THE AUTHOR BRINGING IT FORWARD --
AND I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
MEMBERS HERE WHO HAVE -- HELPED
UP THIS UP.
GRAY HAIRED GRANDFATHER.
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT -- THOSE
WHO ARE MUCH YOUNGER AND WHO
HAVE LITTLE CHILDREN.
OF FACE FROM TIME TO TIME.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT -- IT IS HERE IN FRONT OF
US AND AND WE CAN VOTE ON IT
ALSO.
REMINDS ME THAT -- I I ACTUALLY
HAVE A UP AND COMING PATTERSON
BACK IN MY DISTRICT TO IS MY
DAUGHTER WHO HAS TWO LITTLE
KIDDOS [inaudible]
AND IF SHE FOLLOWS IN PAPA'S
FOOTSTEPS MAYBE SHE MAY BE
RUNNING.
SO PUTTING ALL THIS TOGETHER AND
THINKING ABOUT IT IN TERMS OF
FAIRNESS AND OPPORTUNITY -- THIS
GIVES US A GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY YES. TO OUT INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE THE DESIRE TO SERVE AND YET
HAVE THESE CHALLENGES -- DAY
TODAY SO I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THERE WAS PATTERSON MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WASN'T GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS
BUT I DO WANT TO ALSO RECOGNIZE.
IMPORTANT GROUP OF PEOPLE ARE
SINGLE DADS WHO ARE TRYING. TO
GET OUT THERE AND AND AND DO THE
RIGHT THING AND DO RIGHT BY
THEIR CHILDREN TO THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR SINGLE MOMS WE HAD
A LOT OF TO I'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER SINGLE
MOMS -- ABOUT THIS I'VE BEEN A
SINGLE FATHER SINCE MY GIRLS.
WERE TWO AND FOUR IT HAS BEEN
THE MOST CHALLENGING THING I'VE
DONE IN MY LIFE IT'S BEEN THE
MOST REWARDING THING I'VE DONE
IN MY LIFE I WENT THROUGH THE
TWENTY TWELVE AND FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN ELECTIONS --
WITH THEM DRAGGING THEM OUT.
YOU GET TO HEAR DADDY MAKE A
SPEECH AGAIN WAS THAT.
AND THEY THE THE CLAP INITIALLY
MR BLOOM BUT TAX.
BUT BUT NOT OFTEN NOT OFTEN
ENOUGH BUT IT IS THE CHALLENGES
THAT YOU FACE WITH HAVING TO GET
UP.
YOU LOOK OUT AT THEM SITTING OUT
THERE MAKING SURE NO ONE'S GOING
UP.
NEXT TO THEM TO TO TO TALK TO
THEM OR OTHERWISE BOTHER MAKE
SURE THEY STAY WHERE THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE -- MAKE SURE THEY
EAT COME HOME MAKE LUNCHES FOR
THE NEXT DAY BE TOLD THEY NEED
TO BRING CUPCAKES.
OR WHATEVER ELSE OR A GIFT THIS
IS A TOUGH JOB I'M WATCHING MY
DAUGHTERS MY DAUGHTER HAS A
RECITAL.
TODAY I'LL BE AND FORCE YOU
WATCHING ON YOUTUBE I FLEW HOME
FOR PRACTICES -- BECAUSE I CUT
CONTINUE TO COACH THEIR TEAMS IT
IS THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT JOB
TO DO UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES
IS INCREDIBLY INCREDIBLY.
DIFFICULT AS A SINGLE PARENT MY
HAT'S GO OUT TO EVERY SINGLE
PARENT IN THIS ROOM WE NEED THAT
AS A VALUED VIEWPOINT WE TALK
ABOUT QUALITY OF LIFE.
IN HERE AND I THINK THE SINGLE
PARENTS HAVE A LOT TO OFFER ON
HOW HARD IT IS EVEN TO GET HERE
ON MONDAY MORNINGS IF YOU WANT
TO TAKE YOUR KIDS TO SCHOOL.
SO I THINK ALL OF US SINGLE MOMS
SINGLE DADS HAVE A LOT TO OFFER
THIS DISCUSSION I THINK IT'S A
VALUED VOICE THAT WE NEED IN
THIS CHAMBER.
I AM VERY VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU THIS MAIENSCHEIN THANK
YOU MEMBERS SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEE RECOGNITION.
ON THE ITEM MISTER MONTE MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES.
FOR THE DEBATE FOR THE THE WORDS
OF SUPPORT ALSO FOR THE
CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM I I DO
WANT TO PUSH BACK ON ON ONE ITEM.
THAT THAT THIS IS SOMEHOW A BILL
THAT FOR THE ELITE JUST FOR US.
FOR THE PROVIDE SPECIAL
TREATMENT AND THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS IT'S THE OPPOSITE.
THIS BILL IS FOR EVERYONE.
THIS BILL IS FOR ANYONE.
THIS BILL IS FOR THE EVERYDAY
PERSON IN CALIFORNIA ANY
CALIFORNIAN WHOEVER DREAMED OF
RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
WHO WANTED TO SERVE AND HAVE A
VOICE IN THERE?
AT THE LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD OR
THEIR HEALTHCARE DISTRICT OTHER
CITY COUNCIL MAYBE THEY DREAMED
OF RUNNING FOR STATE LEGISLATOR
SOMEDAY OR EVEN CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICE BUT THE WHOLE IDEA OF
THIS BILL IS TO REMOVE A BARRIER.
TO EVERY CALIFORNIAN WHO SEES
THEM IN THEIR WAY.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING.
WE ARE BEING DEPRIVED OF
CRITICAL VOICES ON THIS FLOOR
AND IN CHAMBERS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
THE VOICES OF OF PARENTS THE
VOICES OF WOMEN.
THAT GENDER INEQUITIES CLEAR AND
IT NEEDS TO BE FIXED AND THIS IS
ONE COMMONSENSE WAY. TO HELP
ADDRESS THAT I DO WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FROM NICOLAS FOR
SPECIFY ONE PART ABOUT THE BILL
THAT WE DO INTEND TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS ON IN THE AND THE
OTHER CHAMBER FOR GETS OFF THE
FLOOR TODAY AND THAT'S TO
CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL APPLIES.
FOR CAMPAIGN RELATED ACTIVITY
ONLY NOT WHAT WHILE IN YOUR
OFFICIAL DUTIES WE THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE BILL WE
DO EXPECT TO CLARIFY THAT -- BUT
MAKE NO MISTAKE THIS IS TO TO
REMOVE BARRIERS THAT ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO SERVE THEIR COMMUNITY
CAN STEP UP AND DO SO -- FREE OF
BARRIERS THAT AFFECT PARENTS IN
AFFECT WOMEN -- WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR THANK YOU.
THEY RESPONDED WITH THAT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
RYSZARD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE THE ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY FOUR
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTEEN A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY
TWO BY MISS CARILLO CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO AND
EXPLAINED FAMILY PHYSICIANS.
MS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO
WHICH SIX TO PROTECT PATIENT
ACCESS AND BETTER UTILIZE.
CALIFORNIA'S POSITIONS WORKFORCE
BY I'M AMENDING STATUTORY
LANGUAGE TO MORE ACCURATELY
REFLECT THE TRAINING AND
EXPERTISE OF OUR FAMILY
PHYSICIANS.
FAMILY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN
RECEIVE SPECIALIZED TRAINING AND
PREVENTIVE AND PRIMARY CARE FOR
PEOPLE FROM BIRTH TO END OF LIFE.
WHICH MAKES THEM UNIQUE IN THE
BREADTH OF KNOWLEDGE AND ABILITY
TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY CARE TO
PATIENTS ACROSS ALL SETTINGS.
UNFORTUNATELY A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF FAMILY MEDICINE
HAS RESULTED IN THE UNDER
UTILISATION OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
LIMITING ACCESS TO CARE
RESTRICTING PATIENT CHOICE AND
DISRUPTING.
THE CONTINUITY OF CARE AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO WILL REMEDY
THIS PROBLEM BY SIMPLY FIXING
INCONSISTENCIES IN THE LAW TO
MORE ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
TRAINING AND EXPERTISE OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS.
AND TO IMPROVE PATIENT ACCESS
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
DAVIS GRILL.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ADAM.
CAR CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
THE ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIES BUT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS NINETEEN AND TWENTY
PASS RETAIN FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE
IS AB.
ONE SEVENTY NINE COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND
ACTUALLY THE NEW MOTOR VEHICLES.
ISRAEL'S.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TO THEIR PRESENT AB ONE
SEVENTY NINE A BILL THAT MAKES
CHANGES TO THE FRANCHISE
RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS AND AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS.
NEW CAR DEALERS OPERATING AS
LOCAL INDEPENDENTLY OWNED
FRANCHISED DEALERSHIPS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES EMPLOY OVER FOUR TO
ONE HUNDRED I'M SORRY EMPLOY
OVER ONE HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IN SOME COMMUNITIES ARE THE
MAJOR SOURCES OF ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT THE
BALANCE OF POWER BETWEEN LARGE
MULTINATIONAL AUTO MAKERS AND
CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR DEALERS IS
A FAIR AND COMPETITIVE PLAYING
FIELD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT JOBS BILL.
THANK YOU ADDRESS A SAYNO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO IS AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE I MISTER
CUNNINGHAM CLICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER CUNNINGHAM
AND OTHERS AND I FIND
INFORMATION PRIVACY.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS TODAY I'D LIKE TO
PRESENT AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
THE ANTI EAVESDROPPING ACT.
PRIVACY IS A RIGHT IN OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION.
OUR PENAL CODE PROTECT PRIVACY
BY MAKING IT A CRIME A CRIME
MEMBERS TO RECORD A CONVERSATION.
WHERE THERE IS AN EXPECTATION OF
PRIVACY WITHOUT CONSENT?
THE THIRD AND FOURTH AMENDMENTS
TO OURS CONSTITUTION AND THE
BILL OF RIGHTS.
PROTECT.
THE HOME FROM UNWARRANTED
GOVERNMENT INTRUSION.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S A NEW THREAD
EMERGING TO OUR PRIVACY RIGHTS.
THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY SPORTS
SPEAKERS ARE WONDERFUL DEVICES
THEY IMPROVE OUR LIVES AND THEY
HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO IMPROVE
OUR HOMES AND OUR AND OUR
QUALITY OF LIFE EVEN MORE.
BUT IS COME TO PASS AND IT IS
COME TO LIGHT.
THAT THOSE DEVICES ALSO ARE A
THREAT TO OUR PRIVACY BECAUSE
THEY CAN AND DO RECORD
CONVERSATIONS.
THAT ARE PRIVATE WITHIN OUR HOME
AND THAT THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
SHARED.
AND SOLD WITHOUT OUR CONSENT.
THAT IS WHAT MY BILL SEEKS
[inaudible]
TO PREVENT.
THERE IS NO WHERE WHERE THE
RIGHT TO PRIVACY IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN IN OUR HOMES
THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE OUR MOST
IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS OF OUR
LIVES.
WE TELL OUR KIDS TO PICK UP THE
ROOMS.
WHEN THEY DON'T WE YELL AT THEM
TO PICK UP THE ROOMS?
WE DISCUSS POLITICS.
WE WATCH FOX NEWS SOME OF US WE
WATCH CNN OTHERS WE ALL THE TV
WE DEBATE WE ARGUE.
WE HAVE THESE PERSONAL
CONVERSATIONS WITHIN THE SECTOR
OF OUR HOMES BECAUSE WE PROTECT
AND TRUST THAT THEY'RE NOT GONNA
BE RECORDED WITHOUT OUR CONSENT
BUT THAT IS HAPPENING.
I'D I COMMIT TO YOU AND I'VE
COMMITTED TO MANY MANY MEMBERS
ON THIS.
FOR WE WILL WORK ON THIS BILL WE
WE HAVE ENGAGE WITH INDUSTRY WE
HAVE ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
AND I WILL NOT BRING A BILL BACK
FROM THE SENATE.
UNLESS WE HAVE FIXED ALL THE
ISSUES THAT REMAIN WITH IT.
AND WE PRODUCED IT TO ITS CORE
INTENT WHICH IS TO RESTORE THE
BASELINE OF TRUST.
THAT WE ALL HAVE AND NOT BASED
ON A TRUST MEMBERS IS IS GOING
TO ALLOW THESE DEVICES TO
DEVELOP AND FLOURISH THAT TRUST
HAS BEEN BREACHED.
WE NEED TO RESTORE IT THIS IS A
POSITIVE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AND I THINK IT'S TIME WE GIVE
CONSUMERS BACK THE CONTROL AND
THE CHOICE.
SO THAT WHEN THEY CHOOSE TO
BRING A SPEAKER INTO THEIR HOME.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GETTING
INTO.
AND THEY CAN CONSENT BEFORE THEY
ARE RECORDED.
THIS AS A BIPARTISAN AUTHORSHIP
IT CAME OUT OF PRIVACY COMMITTEE
IT'S NOW BETTER WORK PRODUCT.
WE'RE STILL REFINING IT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BOAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM IS
WORKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE AS A CO AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL AND IT'S A VERY
SIMPLE BILL.
IT BASICALLY SAYS THAT IF YOU'VE
A VOICE RECORDER IN YOUR HOUSE.
THAT YOU GIVE CONSENT FOR THIS
RECORDER TO RECORD YOUR CONTENT
AND THAT YOU KNOW IF THAT
COMPANIES GOING TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION.
IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE WILL IT'S A
BASIC PRIVACY -- CONSUMER
PROTECTION BILL THAT I THINK IS
NECESSARY AS TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATES AND I USED TECHNOLOGY
I'M A CONSUMER OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AS WELL.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
OUR OUR OUR CUSTOMERS AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND OUR VOTERS KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THIS DATA.
AND AND AND CONSENT TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING IT'S A VERY SIMPLE
BILL I AM HONORED TO WORK WITH
MY COLLEAGUES ON THIS AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS WITH MISS ROBIN
ULTI CORRECTNESS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
RELUCTANT OPPOSITION TO AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE AS STATED.
RIGHT NOW THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT THE SALE OF VOICE
ACTIVATED SPEAKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I KNOW EVERYONE SAYING NO NO
WAIT THAT'S NOT WHAT THE BILL
SAYS BUT I KNOW OF WHAT I SPEAK
SO IN REAL LIFE I OWN A SOFTWARE
DEVELOPMENT COMPANY AND ABOUT
TEN YEARS AGO WE DID.
A VOICE ACTIVATED TOY THAT YOU
COMMUNICATED WITH BY SPEAKING TO
IT.
AND SO I'VE WRITTEN A SOFTWARE
THAT INTERFACES WITH ONE OF THE
EARLY VOICE ACTIVATION SHIPS
UNDER THE CURRENT PRODUCTS OR AN
ORDER OF MAGNITUDE MORE
SOPHISTICATED THAN WHAT WE DID
TEN YEARS AGO BUT I KNOW ABOUT
THE SONG THE THE THE PROCEDURES
THAT YOU'D HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SAYING.
AND THE PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL
STEMS FROM THE INCLUSION OF A
SINGLE WORD OF THE BILL WHICH IS
THE WORD RETAIN.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
PROHIBITING.
THE SALE OR THE SHARING OF
INFORMATION WITH THIRD PARTIES I
THINK THAT THAT IS APPROPRIATE
BUT NOT ALLOWING THE DEVICE TO
RETAIN A USER'S VOICE RECORDED
ON THE DEVICE.
WOULD PROHIBIT THE VOICE FROM --
THE DEVICE FROM FUNCTIONING AT
ALL AND IRONICALLY ONE OF THE
SITUATIONS THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT WITH THIS BILL WAS HEARD
AND PRIVACY.
WAS THE FACT THAT THERE IS
CONCERN THAT WHEN YOU SPEAK THE
WAKE WORD. TO A DEVICE THAT THAT
WOULD THE VOICES IN THE DEVICES
SUPPOSED TO WAKE UP AND START
LISTENING TO WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY AND THERE'S CONCERN THAT
SOMETIMES.
THE DEVICE THINK SAID HERE'S THE
WAKE WORD BUT IT ACTUALLY DIDN'T.
AND SO WE CAN RECORD THINGS THAT
ARE INAPPROPRIATE RIGHT I THINK
THAT THAT IS A VALID CONCERN BUT
IRONICALLY PROHIBITING THE
DEVICE FROM RETAINING YOUR VOICE
AND LEARNING FROM YOUR VOICE AND
GETTING TRAINED IN.
WHAT YOU SOUND LIKE WHEN YOU SAY
THE WAKE WORD MAKES IT A LOT
MORE LIKELY THAT THE DEVICE WILL
WAKE UP AT AN APPROPRIATE TIME
SAID RECORDED APPROPRIATE
CONVERSATION SO I URGE THE
AUTHOR? TO TAKE A SERIOUS LOOK
AT THIS I'M IN SUPPORT OF THAT
THE ENTIRETY OF THE REST OF THE
BILL EXCEPT THAT THAT ONE PART
RETAIN I'VE SERIOUS TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS WITH SO FOR NOW I
ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK A MEASURE OF REALTY DOCTOR
QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ALL
RIGHT.
I HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS AS MR
OBERNOLTE BUT I ARJUN AYE VOTE.
I WENT OVER AND TALKED TO THE
AUTHOR AND EXPLAIN TO HIM THAT
IF YOU DON'T ALLOW SOMETHING TO
BE STORED YOU CAN'T UNDERSTAND.
THAT PERSON'S VOICE FURTHER ALL
THOSE STORED VOICES THEY USE A
I'D. TO DETERMINE.
THE BEST WAY TO INTERPRET PEOPLE
WITH ACCENTS AT CETERA AND IT
JUST GETS BETTER AND BETTER IF
YOU STORAGE.
WHAT THE PROBLEM IS IS THEN
GIVING IT TO SOMEONE ELSE I HAVE
SPOKEN WITH THE AUTHOR?
I BELIEVE HE UNDERSTANDS THIS
POINT AS BROUGHT UP BY MR
OBERNOLTE.
I AGREE WITH THE POINT I BELIEVE
THAT THE AUTHOR IS WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION PLEASE LET THIS
BILL GO TO THE SENATE IF IT'S
STILL A PROBLEM WHEN IT COMES
BACK WE CAN LOOK AT IT THEN.
BUT I WOULD URGE KNIFE OF THANK
YOU DOCTOR QUIRK SEE NO.
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM MISTER MISTER CUNNINGHAM
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THE INPUT FROM
TWO VERY VERY.
RESPECTED AND INTELLIGENT
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY I THINK THE
MEMBER FROM HAYWARD.
SAID IT BETTER AND I COULD LET'S
KEEP IT MOVING.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS IN THE SENATE AND I'M
TRYING TO STRIKE THAT BALANCE
THAT ALLOWS THE TECHNOLOGY TO
IMPROVE.
SO WE CAN ALL ENJOY THESE
DEVICES IN OUR HOME BUT MAKE
SURE THAT.
WHAT YOU SAY? TO YOUR
SIGNIFICANT OTHER OR YOUR KIDS
IN YOUR HOME DOES NOT END UP
PACKED IN OUT THERE FOR THE
WORLD TO USE AS IT SEES FIT
WITHOUT YOUR CONSENT.
THANK YOU ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY BOOK.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE OF ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE
.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM MOVES A CALL
BACK IN FIVE MEMBERS FOUND
TWENTY THREE PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR IS AB
EIGHT FORTY SIX MS BURKE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY SIX BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BURKE AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN CONSUMER
PRIVACY.
THIS BURKE.
IS NOT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I AB EIGHT FORTY SIX CLARIFIES
THAT THE CAN CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT IS NOT INTENDED TO
PROHIBIT BUSINESSES FROM
OFFERING CUSTOMER LOYALTY
PROGRAMS.
WITH THE CURRENT LANGUAGE IN THE
C. C. P. A BUSINESSES ARE
QUESTIONING WHAT THEY CAN AND
CANNOT DO WITH THEIR CUSTOMER
LOYALTY PROGRAMS.
AND ARE SEEKING CLARITY IN THE
LAW TO CONTINUE THEIR OFFERINGS
AS AMENDED AB EIGHT FORTY SIX
CREATE A SEPARATE SECTION WITHIN
THE CCP A TO EXPLICITLY CLARIFY
THAT CONSUMERS CAN CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN THESE PROGRAMS IF THEY CHOOSE
TO DO SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU MS BURKE SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLICK BELOW FOR THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY KNOWS.
ONE DAMAGE YOUR PASSES.
FILE ITEMS.
TWENTY FIVE THREE TWENTY SEVEN
PASS AND RETAIN FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT AB THIRTEEN NINETY SIX
CROCKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY NINETY SIX
BY SOMETHING NUMBER OBERNOLTE
AND ACTUALLY PROTECTIVE ORDERS
THE SERVER NOTING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THE
ISSUE OF ELDER ABUSE AS A LARGE
AND GROWING PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
ON AGING ONE IN TOWN ELDERS HAVE
SUFFERED SOME KIND OF ABUSE.
AND YET ONLY ONE IN FOURTEEN
CASES OF ABUSE EVEN GETS
REPORTED THIS IS AN ESPECIALLY
ACUTE PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
ESTIMATED BY THE U. S. CENSUS.
THAT BY THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE THE OLDER POPULATION WILL
HAVE DOUBLED IN CALIFORNIA AND
YET CALIFORNIA HAS A HIGHER
ELDER ABUSE RATE.
OF ANY STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
THIS BILL WOULD SEEK TO IN SMALL
PART ADDRESS THAT SITUATION BY
EMPOWERING A JUDGE WHEN GRANTING
ELDER ABUSE RESTRAINING ORDER.
TO ORDER THE OFFENDER TO EITHER
CLINICAL COUNSELING OR ANGER
MANAGEMENT CLASSES.
JUDGES ALREADY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THIS IN THE CASE
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS THIS WOULD EXTEND THAT
AUTHORITY TO ELDER ABUSE
RESTRAINING ORDERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX THANK YOU
MISS ROBIN ALL THE SAME NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT EYES.
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE IN TWENTY NINE IS A BE TEN
SEVENTY TWO CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
MISTER PATTERSON.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS -- AB
TEN SEVENTY TWO PROVIDES CLARITY
TO SMALL WATER AND TELEPHONE
PROVIDERS ABOUT THE TIMELINE
UNDER WHICH THE CPU SEAT MUST
COMPLETE AN AUDIT OR REVIEW.
OF THEIR UTILITY IT ALSO AVOIDS
DUPLICATION OF UNNECESSARY WORK
WHEN A GENERAL RATE CASES BEING
COMPLETED FINALLY THIS BILL
ENSURES TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING THE PC TO PUBLICLY
POST THEIR AUDITING PROCESSES.
AND THEIR STANDARD JUST RECEIVED --
YOU NOT A SUPPORT NO NO VOTES
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ADAM.
CLARK LOCAL ORAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESERVE AT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE THE ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE
TO VOTE [inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AN ICE.
FIFTY SIX NOW ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM THIRTY PASS
RETAIN FILE ITEM.
THIRTY ONE THIS A. B. ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN BY MISTER SANTIAGO
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN NINETY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING NUMBER
SANTIAGO AND ACTUALLY TO BUY
MENTAL QUALITY.
MR SANTIAGO.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL WOULD CLARIFY -- LIMITED
SEQUEL PROCESS AN EXEMPTION FOR
PROJECTS AND ACTIVITIES CARRIED
BY THE CITY LOS ANGELES -- THAT
ARE FUNDED BY HHH WAS THAT ARE
HOMELESS DOLLARS ARE ALSO FUNDED
BY THE HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAM WHICH IS STATE PASSED
LAST YEAR OFFER EMERGENCY
SHELTERS.
RECENT AMENDMENTS REMOVES ALL
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION OF IT ON
THE ADAM CLARK LOCAL ORAL
[inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THIRTY TO PASS AND
RETAIN FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE IS
AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN OPERATE.
AT SOME LEVEL FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
AND ACTUALLY TRANSPORTATION.
MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TO THEIR PRESENTING AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN A SIMPLE BILL WHICH
PROPOSES TO DISSOLVE THE
EXISTING OMNITRANS JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY.
AND REFORM IT WITH REFORM IT
INTO ON THE TRANCE SPECIAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT.
THIS IS NECESSARY FOR ON THE
TRANS TO RESPONSIBLY EXPANDED
SERVICE TO INCLUDE THE REDLANDS
PASSENGER RAIL PROJECT WHICH
WILL CONNECT COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE INLAND EMPIRE. TO
FURTHER PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN LAST WEEK
REMOVED ALL REGISTERED
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
FINE TUNE THE LANGUAGE IN THE
NEXT HOUSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RESI NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS ARE IS OUR VOTE CLERK
WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED WHAT EYES FIFTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PAST RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS.
THIRTY FOUR THREE THIRTY SIX
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN AB.
SIX BY MS RADIUS.
BY MISS RAINES.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION.
HIS RACE YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I PRESENT AB SIX A BILL WHICH
CREATES THE BRANCH OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
INCREASING THE CAPACITY IN
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR ALL
EARLY CHILDHOOD PROGRAMMING.
THIS GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE CAME
AS A RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
SPEAKERS BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
ON EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
THIS COMMISSION WORKED
DILIGENTLY FOR TWO YEARS OF
ASSESSING ALL ASPECTS OF THE
VERY COMPLEX.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
STRUCTURE WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THERE AFTER PREPARED A
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT.
WITH A LONGER RARE PLANTS TO
EXPAND EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
FROM CHILD CARE TO PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
WE ELEVATE EXISTING GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE.
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THE COMING INFLUX OF
PROGRAM EXPANSIONS.
THE VERY NATURE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION REQUIRES A
VARIETY OF STATE DEPARTMENTS.
A MIXED METHODS DELIVERY SYSTEM
OF CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL AND
HAS A DIVERSE ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS WITH PARTICULAR
NEEDS.
THE COORDINATION OF EFFORTS
WITHIN THE NEW BRANCH OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL EARLY CHILDHOOD
PROGRAMMING REMAINS COORDINATED
AND EFFICIENT.
HIGH QUALITY AND SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
PROVIDERS THAT ARE SERVED
THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT HIGH
QUALITY EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION IS THE GREATEST
EQUALIZER THE CALIFORNIA SHOULD
PROVIDE FOR OUR FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN.
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
BRANCH OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WILL ENSURE THAT WE
PROVIDE THE SOCIO ECONOMICALLY
AND DEVELOPMENTALLY
TRANSFORMATIVE PROGRAMS.
IN AN EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
MANNER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU IS REYES SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE OF A ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WORK WILL.
CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I SIXTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY EIGHT IS AB TWENTY THREE
BY MS BURKE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BURKE AND
ACTUALLY THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
THIS BURKE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE WHICH
ESTABLISHES A DEPUTY A BUSINESS
AND WORK FORCE COORDINATION
WITHIN GOBIZ.
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS PLAYS
A VITAL ROLE IN THE CONTINUE
PROSPERITY OF THE STATE'S
ECONOMY ACCOUNTING FOR OVER 83%
OF THE NET NEW JOBS CREATED LAST
YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SUCCESSES
THREATENED BY A POTENTIAL
SHORTAGE OF ONE TO ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION QUALIFIED WORKERS
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE WOULD ESTABLISH A
DEPUTY A BUSINESS AND WORKFORCE
COORDINATION WITH INGLE BIDS AND
ENGAGE SMALL BUSINESS ON THEIR
LABOR NEEDS TO BETTER ALIGN
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
WITH EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE LABOR MARKET AB TWENTY THREE
IS SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION.
AND HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN RISK SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I BILL.
THANK YOU MS FOR SEEING NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM CLICK
LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF SORRY ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM.
THIRTY NINE AB THIRTY FIVE BY
MISTER KALRA COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY FIVE BY
FAMILY MEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU -- SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
THIRTY FIVE WOULD IMPROVE HOW
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE MADE
AWARE OF AND HANDLE CASES OF
LEAD POISONING AMONG WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WOULD HELP PREVENT REPEATED
OR PROLONGED INCIDENTS OF LEAD
POISONING AND WORKPLACES.
LEAD POISONING CAN CAUSE HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE COGNITIVE DIFF A
DIFFICULT HE'S RESULT
MISCARRIAGES OR PREMATURE BIRTH
A PREGNANT WOMAN.
AND ALSO CAUSE IRREPARABLE
DAMAGE TO OUR NERVOUS SYSTEM AND
KIDNEYS.
AS WE ALL KNOW LET CAN HAVE
PROFOUND AND PERMANENT ADVERSE
HEALTH EFFECTS OF BOTH CHILDREN
AND ADULTS.
AND AT HIGH LEVELS LEAD
POISONING CAN BE FATAL.
LONG AND REPEATED CASES OF LEAD
POISONING ARE ENTIRELY
PREVENTABLE BUT THE PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE CURRENTLY DO NOT WORK.
AT THIS TIME THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS DISCRETION
WHETHER SHE REFERRED CASES OF
THAT PLAYS INTO CAL OSHA.
AS A RESULT MANY EMPLOYEES CAN
REMAIN VULNERABLE TO REPEATED
LET EXPOSURE FOR INDETERMINATE
AMOUNTS OF TIME.
WE HAVE EVIDENCE THAT SHOWS
WHERE HUNDREDS OF BUSINESSES HAD
WORKERS POISONED BY LEAD YEAR
AFTER YEAR A PART IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPENDS UP BY SAYING
THEY'RE WORKING ON THE PROBLEM.
THIS LACKS ADMINISTRATION THE
LOLLIES TO CASES LIKE THE
RECENTLY DISCOVERED GUN RANGE IN
MILPITAS WERE SUCH HIGH LEVELS A
LETTER BEING SPREAD INTO THE
SURROUNDING AREA.
THAT THE ADJACENT CHILDREN'S
GYMNASTICS CENTER ARE PROTESTING
FOR HIGH LEAD LEVELS HAD TO BE
SHUTTERED AND THE CHILDREN BEING
TESTED FOR LEAD POISONING.
AB THIRTY FIVE IS A MODEST AND
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO HELP
ENSURE THAT PROPER NOTIFICATIONS
AND FOLLOW UP BETWEEN CITY PH
AND CAL OSHA ARE MADE.
IN ORDER O PROTECT OF PROTECT
PRESENT AND FUTURE WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES CAL
OSHA INVESTIGATE WORK SITES THAT
HAVE WORKERS WITH ELEVATED BLOOD
LEAD LEVELS UPON RECEIVING SUCH
REPORTS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
IT'S ALSO GOOD FOR BUSINESSES
AND EMPLOYERS BECAUSE THEY CAN
IDENTIFY ISSUES SOONER RATHER
THAN MANY YEARS LATER WHEN IT'S
WAY MORE COSTLY FOR THEM TO
RECTIFY THE SITUATION OR THEY
MAY BE SUBJECT TO LAWSUITS --
FURTHER DOWN THE LINE.
WORKER SAFETY SHOULD BE
PARAMOUNT NOT JUST TO BUSINESSES
BUT ALSO TO THE AGENCIES TASKED
WITH PROTECTING THESE WORKERS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BOAT.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA SEE NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ADAM.
LOCAL TO THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE RESERVE THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE
.
THIS TAKES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FORTY TWO KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY THAT IS AB.
FORTY FOUR BY MISS FRIEDMAN
QUICKLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACTUALLY THE FOR PRODUCTS MS
FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FORTY FOUR WOULD MAKE
IT UNLAWFUL TO SELLER
MANUFACTURE A NEW FOR PRODUCT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
NOW TO BE CLEAR MEMBERS FOR IS
NOT A BY PRODUCT OF THE MEAT
INDUSTRY AND IN FACT THIS BILL
DOES NOT.
I REPEAT IS NOT BANNED FOR FROM
COMMON MEAT ANIMALS FROM SHEEP
FROM THE GOATS ARE FROM CAO SIR
SHEARLING.
AND ANYTHING MADE OUT OF GOAT
SKIN.
OR CAO FOR COULD STILL BE SOLD
OR MANUFACTURED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible] FOR IS
MADE FROM THE FOR OF WILD
ANIMALS WHICH ARE EITHER TRAPPED
IN THE WILD.
OR RAISED IN CAPTIVITY. FOR THE
SOLE PURPOSE.
OF FOR WHICH BECAUSE OF
MANUFACTURING AND BECAUSE OF
SCIENCE AND ADVANCEMENTS WE KNOW
THAT WE CAN MAKE A PERFECTLY
ACCEPTABLE IN FACT A PRODUCT
THAT CAN PASS IS.
FOR THROUGH OTHER MEANS BESIDES
ON THE BACKS OF THE SUFFERING OF
LIVING BEINGS OF ANIMALS.
NOW ALSO TO BE CLEAR.
THESE ARE ANIMALS THAT ARE
MEETING THEIR DEATH EITHER BY
BEING TRAPPED IN THE WILD AND
LEFT SOMETIMES FOR DAYS TO
LANGUISH TRAPS.
AND THE DIRE GROUP TOOK A
GRUESOME DEATH OR RACING
CAPTIVITY AND UNLIKE WITH
DOMESTICATED ANIMALS WILD
ANIMALS.
ARE BY THEIR NATURE WILD THEY
HAVE THEY WANT TO ROME THEY WANT
TO MOVE.
AND WHEN THEY'RE KEPT IN
CAPTIVITY THEY SUFFER.
NOW THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE TOLD US THROUGH THEIR VOTES.
THAT THEY VALUE PROTECTING
ANIMAL WELFARE THEY HAVE VOTED.
TO MAKE SURE THAT FARM ANIMALS
HAVE AMPLE ROOM TO MOVE AROUND
THEY HAVE VOTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT HEN LAYING EGGS.
HAVE ENOUGH ROOM TO LIVE.
LIVS THAT ARE FREE FROM
SUFFERING.
BUT YOU CANNOT TELL CALIFORNIANS
THAT THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY'RE
BUYING.
IN A CLOTHING STORE THAT USED
USES FOR PRODUCTS IS RAISED TO
THE STANDARD TO THE VOTERS HAVE
TOLD US THEY WANT AN ANIMAL
PRODUCTS.
BECAUSE OF THAT MANY OF OUR
MAJOR MANUFACTURERS
MANUFACTURERS LIKE MICHAEL CORES
GUCCI JIMMY CHOO ARMANI BURBERRY
CHANEL VERSACE AND OTHERS.
HAVE ALL ANNOUNCED THAT THEY ARE
NO LONGER USING FOR PRODUCTS IN
FACT ONE OF THEM WROTE THAT THEY
TRIED TO FIND AN ETHICAL SOURCE.
FOR FOR AND WHEN AROUND THE
WORLD LOOKING FOR THAT AND COULD
NOT FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THERE
WAS ANY FOR MANUFACTURE UP TO
THE STANDARDS THAT THEIR
CUSTOMERS WANTED.
AND SO THEY WERE NO LONGER
COULDN'T GOING TO USE.
FOR SO YOU MAY ASK WHY DO WE
NEED THIS OF SO MANY
MANUFACTURERS ALREADY TURNING
AWAY FROM.
FOR THE REASON IS BECAUSE OUR
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA WANT TO
KNOW THAT WHEN THEY BUY A
PRODUCT OFF OF THE SHELVES IT'S
SAFE.
AND THEY ALSO WANT TO KNOW THAT
IF THEY BUY A PRODUCT.
THAT USES ANIMALS OF THOSE
ANIMALS HAVE BEEN HUMANELY
RAISED AND SLAUGHTERED AND WE
CANNOT DO THAT WITH FOR PRODUCTS.
UNLIKE WITH ANIMALS REYES FOR
FOR THERE ARE NO FEDERAL LAWS.
DICTATING HOW FOR BEARING
ANIMALS ARE SLAUGHTERED.
THERE IS NO REGULATION IN THIS
INDUSTRY I AM VERY VERY MANY OF
OUR FOR PRODUCTS ORIGINATE
OVERSEAS WERE OUR LAWS DON'T
TOUCH.
AND IN COUNTRIES WHERE THEY DO
NOT HAVE LAWS AT ALL THAT GOVERN
ANIMAL WELFARE.
MEMBERS THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL FOR THE WELFARE OF ANIMALS
AND IT'S ALSO A BILL THAT IS
PERFECTLY IN KEEPING WITH THE
VALUES OF CALIFORNIA MANY OF OUR
MAJOR CITIES SUCH AS LOS ANGELES
AND SAN FRANCISCO HAVE ALREADY
PASSED BANS.
ON FOR NOW I THINK IT'S TIME FOR
US TO DO THIS STATEWIDE AND TO
SEND A MESSAGE THAT OF ANIMALS
ARE GOING TO BE USED IN ANY
PRODUCT WE DEMAND THAT THE
INDUSTRY SHOW.
THAT THEY'RE HUMANELY RAISED AND
HUMANELY SLAUGHTERED.
BECAUSE THE FOR INDUSTRY IS
UNABLE TO DO THAT.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE I ON AB FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU REST FRIEDMAN.
SAYING IT NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
MISTER CALDERON MOVES A CALL
[inaudible]
SORRY.
MY APOLOGIES MISS FRIEDMAN MOVES
A CALL.
I WAS THINKING OF LAST WEEK MY
APOLOGIES.
BACK ON THE FILE.
FILE ITEM.
FORTY TWO PASS AND RETAIN.
WE'RE BACK TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY ONE THIS IS AB FIFTY
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY BY SOMETHING
CAL.
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SENATE
BILL FIFTY EXPANDS THE ASSISTED
LIVING WAIVER PROGRAM TO MORE
ELIGIBLE MEDI CAL ENROLLEES WHO
CAN BE BETTER SERVED A COMMUNITY
BASED SETTING AT A COST.
SAVINGS TO THE STATE.
OVER A FOUR YEAR PERIOD AB FIFTY
INCREASES THE WAIVER SLOTS FROM
500-070-0404 218-000-5002 KEEP
PACE WITH OUR GROWING AGING
POPULATION AND DEAL WITH THE
OVER FOUR THOUSAND CURRENT.
AND ROLY WAITING LISTS.
ONLY ONLY FIFTEEN COUNTIES ARE
ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM AB FIFTY WOULD EXPAND
THE PROGRAM TO ALL COUNTY IS
INSURING THAT MANY OF THE RULE
COUNTIES THAT CURRENTLY DON'T.
HAVE ACCESS THIS PROGRAM WILL.
THIS IS A LIVING WAIVER PROGRAM
PROVIDES A CRITICAL COMMUNITY
BASED ALTERNATIVES TO
INSTITUTIONALIZATION FOR
ELIGIBLE OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES ON MEDI CAL.
THE WAIVER PROGRAM ALSO LINES
WITH THE STATE'S COMMITMENT.
THE OLMSTEAD DECISION FINDING
THAT THE UNNECESSARY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AS A VIOLATION
OF AMERICANS.
ACT THEREBY ESTABLISHING THE
RIGHT OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES TO RECEIVE SERVICES
IN THE MOST INTEGRATED SETTING.
BUT THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS HAVE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT AYE SIXTY
TWO NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY THREE AB ONE TWO THREE BY
MISTER MCCARTY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB ONE TWO
THREE THE PRESCHOOL FOR ALL ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS
BILL WILL IMPLEMENT TARGETED
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW IT MAY SEEM EASY
PRESCHOOL FOR ALL AS EASY AS ONE
TWO THREE BUT IT'S NOT.
AND FRANKLY IT'S TIME HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
NO THERE ARE STATES ACROSS THE
NATION RED STATES AND BLUE
STATES THAT HAVE GONE ALL OUT
FOR PRESCHOOL FOR ALL.
AND CALIFORNIA'S FRANKLY A
LITTLE BIT BEHIND HERE STATES
LIKE FLORIDA GEORGIA AND
OKLAHOMA ARE LEADING IN THIS
EFFORT TO MAKE SURE THAT KIDS
HAVE YOU NARAL PERSONAL ACCESS
TO EARLY EDUCATION.
BEFORE THEY ENTER KINDERGARTEN.
THIS BILL ACCOMPLICES THIS WITH
A DELICATE BALANCE OF INCREASING
ACCESS WILL ALSO FOCUSING ON OUR
WORK FORCE.
THE MAIN ELEMENTS ARE AS FOLLOWS
IT EXPANDS OUR EXISTING STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE THREE
AND FOUR YEAR OLDS ARE PROVIDED
A SEAT IN OUR EXISTING.
PROGRAMS WE INCREASE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR FUTURE HEAD
PRESCHOOL TEACHERS FOCUSING ON
THE WORK FORCE AND QUALITY AND
FRANKLY I THINK MOST IMPORTANT
FOR ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS.
WE EXPAND ELIGIBILITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
PRESCHOOL BECAUSE WE KNOW WITH
EARLY EDUCATION PRESCHOOL COSTS
IN THE SAME.
AS UC BERKELEY AND UCLA.
THERE ARE TOO MANY KIDS FROM
FAMILIES THAT ARE TOO RICH TO
QUALIFY FOR THE FREE.
BUT TOO POOR TO PAY THE ONE TO
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH IT
COST FOR FULL DAY PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE TRUTH IS IS TOO MANY OF
OUR YOUNGSTERS START
KINDERGARTEN BEHIND ND THEY
NEVER CATCH UP.
THEY NEVER CATCH UP.
SO IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
ADDRESSING INCOME INEQUALITY.
INTER GENERATIONAL POVERTY.
CHILDHOOD POVERTY.
THE APPALLING HIGH SCHOOL DROP
OUT RATE AND EVEN THE CRUEL PATH
TO INCARCERATION THE ISSUES OF
THE DAY THEY WERE ATTEMPTING
ADDRESS WE MUST GET SERIOUS
ABOUT INVESTING IN EARLY
EDUCATION.
AND MAKE PRE K. FOR ALL A
REALITY IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TODAY
SUPPORTED BY A NUMBER OF
EDUCATION EARLY EDUCATION GROUPS
ON BEHALF OF THE TEN PLUS JOINT
AUTHORS OF THIS MEASURE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE RIVAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WAS REGARDING.
MS Là M<c.cyan>.</c>
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
AS A PRODUCT OF STATE PRESCHOOL
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE TWO THREE AS EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE HAS REMAINED A PRIORITY
FOR MANY OF US.
THIS BILL HAS A VERY AMBITIOUS
GOAL.
DATA HAS SHOWN THAT CHILDREN WHO
PARTICIPATE ENRICHMENT PROGRAM
BEFORE ENTERING KINDERGARTEN AND
MORE READY ARE MORE READY TO
LEARN AND PARTICIPATE FULLY IN
SCHOOL.
OVER THEIR COUNTERPARTS WHO DO
NOT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT EARLY LEARNING
EXPERIENCES ARE PARTICULARLY
BENEFICIAL TO CHILDREN WHO ARE
LIVING IN POVERTY.
I WANT TO DRAW ATTENTION TO A
LONG TERM CITY THAT WAS RELEASED
RECENTLY.
MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS AGO
EDUCATORS AND ROLLED.
IN ROLE CHILDREN FROM POOR
FAMILIES IN A PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
[inaudible]
IN MICHIGAN.
WHAT IS NOW KNOWN IS THAT PERRY
PRESCHOOL PROJECT SHOW THAT
EARLY CHILDHOOD INTERVENTION
HAVE POWERFUL EFFECTS FOR
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS?
THE PROGRAM WAS INITIALLY
STARTED TO BOOST THE ACADEMIC
SCORES OF KIDS.
BUT A FEW YEARS THE DATA SHOWED
THAT.
IT DIDN'T DO THAT BUT AS
RESEARCHERS TRACKED THE KIDS
INTO ADULT HOLD INTO ADULTHOOD
THE FOUNDED THE KIDS WHO WENT
THROUGH THE PROGRAM HAD BETTER
LIFE OUTCOMES IN THE KIDS INTO
THE CONTROL GROUP.
THEY HAD MORE EARNINGS MORE
STABLE LONG TERM RELATIONSHIPS
LESS TROUBLE WITH THE LAW.
BUT MOST INTRINSIC INTERESTINGLY
THE RESEARCH CONTINUED AND THE
NEW YORK AND THE NEW WORK
COMPARES THE CHILDREN OF
PARTICIPANTS WHO WENT THROUGH
THE PROGRAM WITH THE CHILDREN OF
PARTICIPANTS WHO WERE IN THE
CONTROL GROUP.
SO WHAT WE ARE SEEING MEMBERS IS
THE INTERVENTIONS TODAY FOR OUR
CHILDREN WILL HAVE GENERATIONAL
IMPACT.
THE CHILDREN OF PARTICIPANTS ARE
HEALTHIER EARNING MORE THEY HAVE
BETTER SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
SKILLS.
ARE MORE LIKELY TO GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL AND GO ON TO COLLEGE.
AND THEY ARE ALSO LESS LIKELY TO
BE INCARCERATED.
EARLY LEARNING AND EARLY
LEARNING INTERVENTIONS WORK
RESEARCH HAS AND CONTINUES TO
PROVE THIS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
START FROM SECOND.
SACRAMENTO AREA HAS LONG BEEN
FOCUSED ON EARLY LEARNING
EXPANSION I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND EIGHTY ONE TWO THREE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS EARLIEST LEARNERS
AND FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
THANK YOU MS ANONYMOUS FRAZIER
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION -- FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO DOES
THIS BILL JUST ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF GENERAL ED STUDENTS OR DOES
IT ALSO INCLUDE.
THE EARLY INTERVENTION FOR THE
ID DEPOPULATION WHEN ASSESSED.
THIS REGARDING YOU MAY ADDRESS
AN HOUR IN A CLOSE.
THIS MCCARTY WILL WAIT TO
ADDRESS THAT AS CLOSENESS
FRAZIER MISTER BONTA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I WANNA FIRST.
THANK MY COLLEAGUE IN SACRAMENTO
FOR HIS CRITICAL LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS NOW AND PROUD TO BE JOIN
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL WHEN IT
COMES EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
WE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE NOT DONE
NEARLY ENOUGH WE NEED.
TO I'D DO BETTER WE NEED TO BE
BOLDER.
AND THIS BILL REALLY POINT US IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION SCIENCE
TELLS US WE NEED TO DO THIS.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE THIRTY MILLION
WORD GAP.
THAT SEPARATES KIDS GROWING UP
IN LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS FROM
THOSE GROWING UP IN HIGHER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS YOU KNOW THAT
90% OF BRAIN DEVELOPMENT OCCURS
BY.
AGE FIVE WE ALSO KNOW THAT
REALLY CHILD EDUCATION.
IS VERY MUCH A SOCIAL JUSTICE
ISSUE WE KNOW THAT ONE'S RACE --
ONES INCOME ONE ZIP CODE SHOULD
NEVER DICTATE ONE'S DESTINY OR
FOR TELL ONCE FUTURE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
PROVIDING ENOUGH EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION TO ENOUGH.
YOUNG PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SO THIS BILL WILL
HELP.
MANY MORE YOUNG PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA REALIZE THEIR DREAMS
AND MEET THEIR FULL POTENTIAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER MONTESINOS
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM MISTER MCCARTY YOU MAY
CLOSE.
I THANK YOU I I WANTED TO
RESPOND TO THE QUESTION MY
COLLEAGUE FROM OAKLEY.
EARLY EDUCATION SPECIFICALLY
STATE PRESCHOOL IS A PROVEN
DIFFERENCE MAKER FOR THOSE WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS AND SPECIAL ED.
AND OUR EXISTING STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM HAS ELEMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ADDRESS KIDS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS AND SO THAT
CERTAINLY IS AN ELEMENT OF OUR
EXISTING STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
WHICH FOR ATTEMPTED TO EXPAND
INTO THIS EFFORT -- BUT ALWAYS
ALL WILL WILL ALWAYS LOOK TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE -- INCREASE
INTERVENTIONS THAT WILL NOT IN
THE BUDGET THAT WE'RE VOTING ON
NEXT WEEK WE DO EXPAND EVEN
FURTHER -- STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS FOR KIDS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS THE AGES. THREE TO FOUR AT
JUST TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
SPOKEN UP ON THIS INTO LIKE I
CORRECT MYSELF THERE ARE
EIGHTEEN JOINT AUTHORS IN TWENTY
THREE CO AUTHORS THIS BILL.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE THE DAY WERE
CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY CAN'T DO
MORE THIS IS A VOLUNTARY --
AFTER HERE THIS IS NOT UNIVERSAL
FOR EVERY KID WE FRANKLY WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE THAT ONE DAY BUT WE
CAN'T AFFORD IT BUT WE SHOULD
MAKE SURE AT LEAST.
ALL KIDS WHO ARE WHO ARE INCOME
ELIGIBLE ARE ABLE TO GO TO EARLY
EDUCATION STATE PRESCHOOL AND
FOCUS ON THE KIDS NEEDED THE
MOST.
WITH THAT ASK FOR YOUR IDOL.
DAVIS MCCARTY CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
THOSE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS I PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL.
ON FILE ITEM FORTY AB FORTY FOUR
MISS FRIEDMAN CORP OPPOSE.
ALL MEMBERS WISH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU THAT I FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS.
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEM. FORTY FOUR IS AB ONE
TWENTY SIX BY MISTER COOPER
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY SIX BY
FAMILY MEMBER COOPER AND
ACTUALLY TO FIGURE AIR POLLUTION.
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB ONE TWENTY SIX MAKES
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT. TO MAKE
THE VEHICLES MORE SENSIBLE
TRIGGERED A NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
DRIVERS AT ALL INCOME LEVELS
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL INCREASES
REBATE LEVELS BY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND LIMITS
ELIGIBILITY FOR HIGH COMMITTED
INDIVIDUALS.
BY BOTH THE REBATE LEVELS FOR
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS AB ONE
TWENTY SIX WILL MAKE CLEAN
VEHICLES MORE SENSIBLE TO
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS.
LIVING COMMUNITIES WITH POOR AIR
QUALITY.
OF THE FORTY WORKING ON THE
MILEAGE RANGE ISSUE TO ASSURE
FOR THE VEHICLES ARE NOT
IMPACTED A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE THING WAS COOPER SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
WELL OVER THE ALL MEMBERS FOR A
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE OF
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE.
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS FORTY FIVE AND
FORTY SIX PASS RETAIN THAT
BRINGS IS FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN
IS.
AB ONE EIGHTY ONE CARILLO.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY ONE BY
SOME THE MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS THIS RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
EIGHTY ONE WHICH PUTS BACK INTO
LAW AND REPORTS. TO THE
LEGISLATOR REGARDING CALPERS AND
CAL STIRS USE OF EMERGING
MANAGERS FOR PURPOSES OF ASSET
MANAGEMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR OUR VOTE.
NAME IS RODRIGUEZ SAYING NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ADAM CLERK
WILL OVER THE ROLE [inaudible]
WELL.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS OF THE
START OF A ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE OF CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NINE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. FIVE
FORTY NINE IS AB TWO THIRTY
CORPORATE.
AS I'M ABLE TO THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO AND ACTUALLY
THE VETERANS.
MR BRO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO
THIRTY IMPLEMENT STATE ATER
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PROGRAM.
THE ORDER FOUND DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS OF NOT BEING PAID FOR
WORK INCLUDED IN THE INITIAL BID.
THE FOCUS IS THE STATE'S
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTY TO ENSURE
THAT COMMITMENTS MADE BY THE
PRIME CONTRACTOR ARM THAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO ASSESS WHERE THE
PROGRAM IS MEETING ITS
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. TO INCREASE
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
PARTICIPATION IN STATE
PROCUREMENT.
THIS SEEKS TO REQUIRE CONSISTENT
COLLECTION AMERICAN VERIFICATION
OF SUBCONTRACTOR PAYMENT DATA TO
ENSURE DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESSES ARE.
BEING USED PROPERLY AND PAID
PROMPTLY THANK YOU AND ASK THREE
AYE VOTE ON AB.
TWO THIRTY AMOS BREAUX SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLE.
THESE ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE HOWEVER I SIXTY SIX
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
JUST TO CLARIFY MEMBERS WE ARE
PASSING TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM.
FORTY EIGHT WHERE PASS.
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM FIFTY
THAT BRINGS IS FILE ITEM.
FIFTY ONE THIS IS MISTER
COOPER'S AB TWO SEVENTY ONE
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER COOPER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE CIVIL
SERVICE THIS COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWO SEVEN ONE WILL HELP CLOSE
THE GENDER AND ETHNICITY PAY GAP.
IN THE UNDER REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES IN ST STILL
SERVICE CLASSIFICATIONS HOWEVER
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES
REMAIN IN ISSUE.
A TWENTY SIXTEEN REPORT FROM THE
CAL HR FOUND THAT WOMEN IN STATE
WORKFORCE -- ABOUT SEVEN CENTS
ON THE DOLLAR COMPARED TO MEN.
AB TWO SEVENTEEN REQUIRE STATE
AGENCY DEPARTMENTS TO PREPARE A
DETAILED REPORT BY AN EARLY.
ON GENDER AND ETHNICITY WAGE
DISPARITY.
AND THEN A REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES ARE
SPECIALLY ASKS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS COOPER MISTER VALLEY HERE
RECOGNIZE.
QUESTION THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
DOES THIS INCLUDE THE THE
LEGISLATORS STAFFS AS WELL.
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
NO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible] ZERO ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE BUT
EYES FIFTY NINE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO
FALLOUT OF FIFTY THREE AB.
THREE ZERO FOUR MISTER JONES
SAWYER CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH FOUR BY
SOME THE MEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
ACTUALLY WIRE TAPPING.
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AB THREE
OH FOUR WOULD EXTEND TO SUNSET
DATE FOR CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
WIRETAP LAW FROM JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY UNTIL JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IN
GENERAL CALIFORNIA LAW PROHIBITS
WIRE TAPPING HOWEVER A SUPREME
COURT JUDGE MAY GRANT A WIRE TAP
IN LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES.
AS FOR THIS BILL THE PROVISIONS
HAVE BEEN PROPERLY BALANCED THE
NEEDS OF PROSECUTING AGE
AGENCIES AND RESIDENTS WITH MORE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS THAN
CURRENTLY PROVIDED. FOR UNDER
FEDERAL LAW WITHOUT AB THROUGH --
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS TO
DISRUPT AND DISMANTLE CRIME
OPERATIONS WOULD BE HINDERED IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE EXTEND
CURRENT LAW AS IT RELATES TO
WIRE TAPS TO MEET THE CHALLENGES
OF CHANGING TECHNOLOGIES AND
CRIMINAL ACTS.
THE BILL WENT THROUGH ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE AYE VOTE.
NAME IS JONES SAWYER SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL.
WHO IS OUR TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE?
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF CLERK
WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY ONE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FIFTY FOUR AB.
THREE THREE TWO CARILLO.
ASSEMBLY WILL THREE THIRTY TO
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER LACKEY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO PEACE
OFFICERS MR LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB THREE THIRTY TWO WILL
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL BARRIERS
WITHIN PEACE OFFICER TRAINING
ACADEMIES.
DURING OUR DISCUSSION LAST
DECEMBER SACRAMENTO POLICE CHIEF
DANIEL HAN MENTION.
THAT ALL THE PEACE OFFICER
TREATIES YOU FILLED OUT OF THE
LAST TWO ACADEMIES.
IN HIS AGENCY WERE EITHER WOMEN
OR PEOPLE OF MINORITY GROUPS.
IN ADDITION SHE FOUND SUGGESTED
THE DO LEARNING THE MAINS.
WITH THE HIGHEST BILL RATES WERE
FIRING PROFICIENCY.
AND VEHICLE OPERATIONS.
THIS BILL WILL DO THREE THINGS.
NUMBER ONE HIGHLIGHT THE SUCCESS
BILL RATE TO THE FIRE ON
PROFICIENCY AND VEHICLE
OPERATIONS DOMAINS NUMBER.
TO REVIEW THE REMEDIATION
STANDARDS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND NUMBER THREE PROVIDE ANY
LEGISLATIVE OR ADMINISTRATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF NECESSARY.
THIS BILL IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WILL DIVERSIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO BECOME MORE REFLECTIVE OF ITS
COMMUNITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKING SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE LOW.
ALL MEMBERS TO RESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
RETAIN A FILE IN A FIFTY FIVE
FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX IS A. B..
FOR TWENTY FIVE SEPARATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR TWENTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND
ACTUALLY IN FIREARMS TO CLING
THERE AND SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MS IRWIN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB FIVE OF FOUR TO FIVE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY -- EIGHTY FOUR TO FIVE
NEARLY EXAMS FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
SECURITY COMPANIES WHICH ALREADY
ARE LICENSED TO CARRY FIREARMS
FROM THE FACE TO FACE
TRANSACTION REQUIREMENT FOR
AMMUNITION PURCHASES.
THESE CHANGES WILL HELP
STREAMLINING CLARIFIED THE
PAPERWORK PROCESS TO HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT THOSE SECURITY
COMPANIES COMPLY WITH THESE NEW
LAWS ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
WORKED WITH THE DOJ ON
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY.
THE PAPERWORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
FILLED OUT BY AGENCIES SO THEY
CAN PROPERLY RECEIVE AMMUNITION
FROM VENDORS OUT OF STATE -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER WOULDN'T SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
RESERVE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY ABOUT I SEVENTY
ONE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY
I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE THAT BILL PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN A.
B. FOR TWENTY EIGHT CORPORATION.
AS A LEGAL FOR TWENTY EIGHT BY
SOME REMEMBER MEDINA AND OTHERS
AND THAT'S WHEN SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FOR TWENTY EIGHT WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED FUNDING. FOR
THE EQUALIZATION OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING RATES FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION PRESCHOOL
SERVICES AND FOR A HIGH COST
PLACEMENTS.
OUR STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS DESERVE HIGH QUALITY OF
EDUCATION WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
BUT OUR CURRENT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING SYSTEM
PRESENTS BARRIERS WHERE THERE
SHOULD BE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
DECADES CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING RATES HAVE
VARIED CONSIDERABLY WITHOUT ANY
RATIONALE.
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN LIVING WITH
THESE INEQUITIES FOR NEARLY FOUR
DECADES AND ADDRESSING THE IT IS
A SIMPLE MATTER OF FAIRNESS.
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL ALSO PRESENTS A
BARRIER WERE AGAIN THERE SHOULD
BE OPPORTUNITY AT A CRITICAL
TIME.
IN CHILDREN'S LIVES.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE A FREE AND
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC EDUCATION TO
PRE SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
BUT IN SPITE OF THIS MANDATE NO
STATE FUNDING IS ALLOCATED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION PRESCHOOL
FUNDING.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM DISCOVERY
BAY -- INDICATED JUST A SHORT
TIME AGO.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE WANT
TO ADDRESS AN A. B..
FOR TWENTY EIGHT FINALLY THE
BILL PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH MORE
SEVERE DISABILITIES.
WHEN OUR CURRENT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCE SYSTEM WAS
ESTABLISHED WE HAD SUPPORT?
BUT IT WAS ELIMINATED DURING THE
RECESSION.
LEAVE IN SCHOOLS WITH NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
HIGHER COSTS PLACEMENTS ALL OF
THE ADJUSTMENTS IN THESE BILLS
ARE COMMONSENSE INVESTMENTS IN
FAIRNESS AND QUALITY FOR OUR
VALUED STUDENTS.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED A NORMAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
SERVICE OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS OF
OUR DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT IS A
BEFORE THIRTY SEVEN COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR THIRTY SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER WHAT IN OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO HOUSING.
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
HOUSING CHALLENGES PEOPLE FACE
TO SECURING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OFTEN INDIVIDUALS CAN MEET THE
MONTHLY COST ASSOCIATE WITH
THEIR HOUSING THE LARGE AMOUNT
OF MONEY NEEDED UP FRONT IS A
BARRIER.
THE RISING DEMAND FOR MORE
HOUSING IS COUPLED WITH THE NEED
TO MAKE HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE.
AND WE KNOW THAT REDDING
CALIFORNIA ARMY CHALLENGE OUR
DEFINITION OF AFFORDABLE.
THE BURDEN OF HIGH RENT COUPLE
WITH OTHER NECESSARY COSTS OF
LIVING LEAVES LITTLE INCOME
AVAILABLE FOR MANY TO AFFORD THE
INITIAL MOVING COSTS ASSOCIATE
WAS SECURING HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA.
LIVING COSTS AS YOUR SECURITY
DEPOSITSIN FIRST MONTH RENT
ASSOCIATE WAS SECURING RENTAL
HOUSING CAN COST TOTALS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO HAVE ON HAND.
WHICH IS UNAFFORDABLE FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
AB FOR THIRTY SEVEN WOULD CREATE
A PROGRAM THAT COULD PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE TO COVER
THESE MOVING COSTS AND INCREASE
HOUSING SECURITY REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEE NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT ICE
FIFTY TWO KNOWS THIRTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS -- WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE UP THE
ASSISTANT SPEAKER PRO TEM'S
BILLS AT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY TWO FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY TWO IS AB EIGHT OH
SEVEN BY MS BAUER K. HAND.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY ONE EIGHT OH SEVEN BY
SOME THE MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN
AND EXPLAINED CAL WORKS TO CLEAN
THEIR INTO THEIR UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
OKAY HAND THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES CHAIR
RICE TO PRESENT AB EIGHT OR
SEVEN WHICH WILL CREATE EQUITY
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
BY REMOVING INCOME EXCLUSIONS
EXCLUSIONS WHICH PENALIZED
FAMILIES ON CAL WORKS FOR
STUDENTS SCHOLARSHIP RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND ANY TRANSFER OF
MONEY FROM ONE ACCOUNT TO
ANOTHER.
ADDITIONALLY AMENDMENTS TAKEN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WOULD
ALSO EXEMPT ALL CENSUS RELATED
INCOME FROM EITHER GOVERNMENT OR
NONPROFIT AGENCY TO ENCOURAGE
PARTICIPATION IN DISADVANTAGED.
COMMUNITIES WE TOOK THIS MOMENT
IN ORDER TO ENSURE A FULL COUNT
IN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE NAY ABLE THESE PEOPLE TO
DO THIS WORK.
THE COW WORKS PROGRAM SERVES
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND LOW
INCOME FAMILIES BY PROVIDING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR HOUSING
FOOD AND OTHER NECESSARY
EXPENSES.
OF THESE FAMILIES TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
RECIPIENTS ARE LIVING IN DEEP
POVERTY.
THIS BILL EXPANDS THE LIST OF
ITEMS EXEMPTED FROM
CONSIDERATION AS INCOME.
AB EIGHT OR SEVEN WILL MAKE THE
FOLLOWING CHANGES TO THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE RELATING TO
EXEMPT INCOME IN THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM.
IT WILL ESTABLISH THE ANY MONEY
RECEIVED BY YOUTH IN THE FAMILY
AS A RESULT OF A SCHOLARSHIP
AWARD IS EXEMPT.
THIS MEANS STUDENTS CAN STRIVE
AND GO TO COLLEGE AND STILL
RECEIVE THE BENEFITS THEY NEED.
IT WILL CLARIFY THE TRANSFER
YOUR RESOURCE FROM ONE ACCOUNT
TO ANOTHER LIKE THE CAL SAVERS
ACCOUNT DOES NOT COUNT AS INCOME.
WE SHOULD WORK TO HAVE FAMILY
SAVE FOR COLLEGE AND NOT
PENALIZE THEM FOR DOING SO.
AND IT WILL ALSO PROVIDE THE
INCOME EXEMPTION TO CAO WORKS
RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO ANY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED BY
GOVERNMENT ENTITY.
MAKING THESE CHANGES IN THE COW
WORKS PROGRAM WILL ENSURE THAT
FAMILIES ARE NOT DISCOURAGED
FROM SAVING.
AND THEIR CHILDREN NOT
DISCOURAGE FROM ACHIEVING THIS
BILL IS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU MS BARRICADE HIM SAY
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARPOOL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS TO ON THE
URGENCY.
I FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS TO ON THE
BILL.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND NOW MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
BE MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO
SIXTEEN FILE ITEM.
TWO ONE SIX THAT IS AB. THIRTEEN
OH NINE CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN OH NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE IS VERY QUE HAN YOU MAY
AGAIN OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB THIRTEEN OH NINE
WOULD PROVIDE CONSUMERS SENATE
DECISIONAL TWO WEEKS TO SIGN UP
FOR INDIVIDUAL INSURANCE
COVERAGE WHEN THE NEW YEAR
BEGINS.
AB THERE CHEN I'D REMOVE THE
OPEN A ROMAN DATE FROM JANUARY
FIFTEENTH TO JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST FOR PEOPLE TO PURCHASE
INDIVIDUAL INSURANCE COVERAGE
FOR OUR STATE EXCHANGE COVERED
CALIFORNIA OR OFF EXCHANGE.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP IN THE
CONTINUED SUCCESS OF THE ACA.
EVERY YEAR CONSUMERS TO PURCHASE
THEIR OWN INSURANCE HAVE TO MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS THAT HAVE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL ON HEALTH
IMPACTS ON THEIR LIVES.
THIS WAS THE FIRST YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA ENDED ITS OPEN
ENROLLMENT ON JANUARY FIFTEENTH
WHICH GAVE CONSUMERS ONLY TWO
WEEKS IN THE NEW YEAR.
AS A RESULT CAVERN CALIFORNIA
SIDE DROP OF 24% IN NEW
ENROLLMENT.
PROVIDING CONSUMERS ADDITIONAL
TIME TO EDUCATE THEMSELVES ABOUT
DIFFERENT COVERAGE OPTIONS IS
THE SENSIBLE THING TO DO
ESPECIALLY DURING A HECTIC AND
STRESSFUL AND OFTEN.
OFTEN COSTLY HOLIDAY SEASON THE
BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IVATT.
FIGURE WAS BURKE ANC NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE [inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS.
FOR THAT MEASURE PASSES MMBERS
WERE TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM.
FIFTY NINE WE'RE GONNA MOOD FILE
ITEM SIXTY THIS IS A BEFORE
SIXTY SIX CORPORAL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY SIX BY
THE COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE AND
I PLAN TO FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU MAIL WITH.
THE COMMISSION SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB FOR SIXTY SIX WILL EXTEND TO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
THE DATE.
UNTIL WHICH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNER FOOD AND AG OFFICE OF
FARM TO FORK WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE GIVING AN OVERVIEW.
OF THE ACCOUNTS AND EXPENDITURES
TRYING TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES TO
OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN AND
COMMUNITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL
THE CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIES
BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE AB FOR
NINETY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
AS LEGAL FOR NINETY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING NUMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTED COMMUNICATIONS OCCURRING
THERE AND SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. TO SANTIAGO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MAY SPEAKER THIS BILL
SIMPLY EXTENT THE DEATH AND
DISABLE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROGRAMS UNTIL -- TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE THIS PROGRAM ALLOWS
CALIFORNIANS HAD DIFFICULTY
USING THE TELEPHONE -- TO HAVE
BASIC TELEPHONE SERVICE I THINK
IMMENSELY -- THANK YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE IT --
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT NOTES HERE ON
THE BILL THIS MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
FILE ITEM.
FILE ITEM -- SIX TWELVE BY
LETTING SIXTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX
TWELVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWELVE BY
FAMILY MEMBER WEBER AND ACTUALLY
THE CALIBRATION.
THIS WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER YES MADAM
CHAIR I I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB SIX TWELVE WHICH WOULD
BUILD UP ON OUR PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION. TO ADDRESS STUDENT
HUNGER ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES ALL
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO ENTER INTO A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING WITH
THE CHANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN ORDER TO
ENABLE QUALIFYING -- FACILITIES
LOCATED ON CAMPUS TO DISSIPATE
IN THE RESTAURANT MEALS PROGRAM
OF CAL FRESH IT WILL INCREASE
STUDENT ACCESS TO THE TO THE
PROGRAM BY STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS BUT COMMITTEE COLLEGES
TO PROVIDE CAL FIRST BENEFITS.
IT IS SPONSORED BY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORTED BY TWELVE TO ME TO
COLLEGES AND DISTRICT AS WELL AS
SEVERAL ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION --
IS OF AS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD COLLEGE
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT BE GOING
HUNGRY THIS IS ONE OF OUR WAYS
TO ADDRESS IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WEBER SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
BOAT.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM SIXTY TWO SIXTY THREE AND
SIXTY FIVE FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX
AB SIX TWENTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY NINE BY
SO MANY MEMBERS MET THAN OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO CRIME VICTIMS
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE.
MISS SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SIX TWENTY NINE IS A
WOMEN'S CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL
THAT WILL HELP VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING REBUILD THEIR LIVES.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS ARE
FORCED TO SUFFER THROUGH A
COMBINATION OF PHYSICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL VIOLENCE.
WHEN THEY LOSE THEIR FREEDOM
THEY ALSO LOSE THEIR ABILITY TO
WORK A REGULAR JOB AND RECEIVE
LEGAL WAGES?
AFTER A VICTIM HAS ESCAPED A
TRAFFICKING SITUATION THE
JOURNEY BACK TO NORMALCY IS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT.
THEY MUST GRAPPLE WITH FINDING
HOUSING AND OTHER BASIC
NECESSITIES ON TOP OF SEEKING
TREATMENT FOR MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
THEY MAY BE ISOLATED FROM
FRIENDS AND FAMILY AND MAY HAVE
TO RESETTLE FAR FROM WHERE THEY
WERE INITIALLY TRAFFICKED IN
ORDER TO BE SAFE AGAIN.
THE WAY CURRENT REGULATIONS ARE
WRITTEN DOES NOT ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES VICTIMS INDOOR
WHILE BEING TRAFFICKED NOR THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE IN RECOVERY.
CALIFORNIA'S VICTIM COMPENSATION
PROGRAM PROVIDES ASSISTANCE TO
VICTIMS WHO HAVE SUFFERED
PHYSICAL INJURY OR THE THREAT OF
PHYSICAL INJURY AS A RESULT OF
VIOLENT CRIME INCLUDING COVERING
UNFORESEEN EXPENSES SUCH AS
MEDICAL BILLS MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT.
FUNERAL AND BURIAL EXPENSES AND
INCOME LOSS HOWEVER UNDER
TODAY'S LAW HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS MAY NOT BE COMPENSATED
FOR INCOME LOSS.
AB SIX TWENTY NINE WILL ALLOW
THE CALIFORNIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD TO COMPENSATE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS FOR
ECONOMIC LOSSES INCURRED AS A
RESULT OF BEING TRAFFICKED.
WE CANNOT UNDO THE HARM THAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS OF
SUSTAINED BUT BY PROVIDING THESE
VICTIMS WITH FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE WE CAN RECOGNIZE THE
ADVERSITY THEY HAVE UNDERGONE.
AND HELP THEM MOVE FORWARD WITH
THEIR LIVES.
THANK YOU MISSUS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER WHICH I CLOSE.
POLITICS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE ABOUT.
THANK YOU KIRK WILL OPEN THEIR
OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE THIS TAKES
[inaudible]
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBER.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I IN
SIXTEEN KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB SIX
FIFTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO WATER.
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
PRESENT ON AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT
WHICH CREATES A NEW PROCESS THAT
WILL ALLOW THE STATE WATER BOARD
TO ISSUE A FIVE YEAR TEMPORARY.
URGENCY PERMITS.
THIS PERMIT WILL ALLOW
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABLE AGENCIES
OR LOCAL AGENCIES TO APPLY FOR
THIS NEW PERMANENT AND DIVERT
WATER TO UNDERGRAD STORAGE
DURING HIGH FLOWS.
ADDING ANOTHER TOOL FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE WHO ARE
FACING DRASTIC CHANGES DUE TO
SIGMA IMPLEMENTATIONS.
AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT WILL HELP
COMMUNITIES AND USERS IN MY
DISTRICT AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA
TO IMPLEMENT SIGMA BY USING
RECHARGE TO ITS FULLEST
POTENTIAL.
MORE FREQUENT AND SEVERE
DROUGHTS COMBINED WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SIGMA ARE GOING
TO VASTLY CHANGED THE LANDSCAPE
OF OUR FARMING AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES.
IF WE DO NOT ADEQUATELY PREPARE.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER ARAMBULA LAST
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL.
LOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE AYE
SIXTY ONE NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT AB SIX
SIXTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ AS
A LEGAL SIX SIXTY ONE BY SOME
THE MEMBER MCCARTY AND ACTUALLY
NON VEHICULAR POLLUTION.
THIS MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER WERE
STILL REELING IN THE STATE FROM
THE IMPACTS OF THE WILD FIRES
THIS PAST FALL -- ONE OF THE
IMPACTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY WAS AIR QUALITY I BELIEVE
IT OR NOT ON THE DAY OF THE THE
THIRD DAY OF THE FIRE.
THEY ARE QUALITY HERE WAS WORSE
IN SACRAMENTO BUT IT WAS UP IN
PARADISE AND ACTUALLY WAS THE
WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE WORLD
THAT DAY.
IN THE WORLD.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION
FOR PARENTS AND FAMILIES WHAT TO
DO WHAT TO DO WITH OUR KIDS WHAT
TO DO WITH SENIORS -- THE COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICER WAS GIVING OUT
CONFLICTING INFORMATION FROM OUR
COUNTY -- ERR ERR BORDER AIR
DISTRICT SO THIS BILL WOULD SET
UP POLICY AND FRANKLY A A MODEL
WERE AT COUNTIES COULD FOCUS ON
WHAT TO DO IN THE EVENT THAT WE
HAVE ANOTHER FIRE LIKE WE
HAPPENED LAST FALL BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS.
THE NEW NORMAL SO THIS WOULD BE
AN EFFORT IT'S WOULD BE A PILOT
JUST WITH OUR SACRAMENTO
MUNICIPAL AIR DISTRICT HAVE THEM
FOCUS WAS SOME EXPERTISE WITH A
RB TO COME OUT WITH SOME -- BEST
PRACTICES STANDARDS FOR WHAT TO
DO WHEN WE HAVE EVENTS.
SUCH AS WE HAD LAST FALL WITH A
DISASTROUS FIRE AND AIR
IMPACTING OUR PUBLIC HEALTH.
ASK DR THANK YOU.
MISS MCCARTY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
MOM MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
VIOLATING SIXTY NINE AB SIX
SIXTY TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM AND
ACTUALLY TO CRIMES SICKENING HIM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AB SIX SIX TWO WOULD MODERNIZE
AN UPDATE PENAL CODE. TWO SIX
SIX TO BE GENDER NEUTRAL THIS
CODE SECTION HAS NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES.
AND DOING SO IN THIS WAY WOULD
GIVE MORE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX
TO FIGHT HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
IT'S RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THUS FAR IN THE PROCESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THE THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY TWO NOTES
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY AB SIX SIXTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY EIGHT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN THE COURT
HOUSES.
THIS CANDOLLARS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SIXTY EIGHT WOULD
PROTECT IMMIGRANTS IN ALL
CALIFORNIANS FROM CIVIL RESTED
COURTHOUSE WHEN THE INDIVIDUAL
IS ATTENDING A COURT PROCEEDING
OR HAS LEGAL BUSINESS IN THE
COURTHOUSE.
ALL THE TRADITIONAL CIVIL RESTED
COURTHOUSES MAY HAVE DECLINED
THEY'RE NOT ENTIRELY DISAPPEARED
IF YOU'RE WITHIN THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY INCREASES WHEN STATE
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE ENTANGLED
WITH FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
THIS MAY RESULT HESITANCY BY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO INTERACT
WITH STATE AGENCIES AND CLAIM
EARNED BENEFITS OR REPEAT REPORT
VIOLATIONS OF STATE LAWS OR
REGULATIONS.
CALIFORNIA MUST PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS RIGHT TO VISIT THE
COURTS AND PARTICIPATE COURT
PROCEEDINGS WITHOUT FEAR OF
ARREST I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
BOATS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE CASH.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
EIGHT NO THIRTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY BY SOME
THE MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS MR CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKERS AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE 2% SB.
SIX EIGHTY SB SIX EIGHTY WERE
REQUIRED TO CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
ARE KNOWN AS POST TO ADOPT
MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHERS.
THEY WILL TAKE A MINIMUM OF FOUR
HOURS OF MENTAL HEALTH I DOES
IDENTIFICATION AND AWARENESS
TRAINING.
IN THEIR BASIC TRAINING AND ONE
HOUR OF CONTINUING TRAINING PER
YEAR.
THIS DISPATCHERS ARE THE FIRST
POINT OF CONTACT FOR EMERGENCY.
THE INFORMATION DAY COLLECTED
AND RELATE TO THE PEACE OFFICER
IS CRUCIAL TO THE OUTCOME OF ANY
POLICE CONTACT.
THIS TRAINING MEANS DISPATCHER
AND RESPONDING OFFICES WILL BE
MORE ALIGNED IN COMMUNICATIONS
AND APPROACHES.
THIS WILL PROTECT ALL INVOLVED
IN IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF
INFORMATION SENT TO A RESPONDING
OFFICERS.
THIS WILL RECEIVE A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM SEVENTY TWO AND SEVENTY
THREE FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR AB
SEVEN FIFTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
AT SOME LEVEL SEVEN FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL AND
OTHERS AND I TELLING PEOPLE SAYS
MINTZ MISTER DON'T KNOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE WILL
INCREASE THE PATHWAY TO COLLEGE
BY PROVIDING ELEVENTH GRADE
STUDENTS ACCESS. TO A COLLEGE
ENTRANCE EXAM.
CURRENTLY STUDENTS IN GRADE
THIRD THROUGH EIGHTH AND THEN
ELEVENTH ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE
THE SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT
TESTS THE STATE REQUIRED TESTS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADMINISTER A
COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAM INSTEAD OF
THE STATE REQUIRED US ASSESSMENT
FOR THE ELEVEN FOR ELEVENTH
GRADE STUDENTS.
THE ALTERNATE ASSESSMENT WE
OFFERED DURING THE SCHOOL DAY AT
NO COST TO STUDENTS.
THIS BILL REQUIRES ASSESSMENT TO
BE A LINE TO THE STATE STANDARDS
MEET FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AND
PROVIDE ACCOMMODATIONS TO E. L.
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE LEVELS THE
PLAYING FIELD BY PROVIDING ALL
STUDENTS ACCESS TO TEST PREP.
AND A SECURE ENVIRONMENT TO TAKE
THE TEST IT IS ABOUT EQUITY AN
OPPORTUNITY.
THIS BILL IS A REINTRODUCTION OF
AB NINETEEN FIFTY ONE FROM LAST
YEAR WHICH RECEIVE NO NO VOTES
IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AMANDA SPEAKER ASKED WE MAKE
COLLEGE ENTRANCE COLLEGE
PREPARATION.
OF THE SCHOOL CULTURE AND I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS -- TO DESERT
APPROACH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE AB SEVEN
SIXTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOMETHING ALL SEVEN SIXTY NINE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER SMITH AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
THIS MAKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB SEVEN SIX NINE
WOULD ADD LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELORS TO THE LIST
OF PROVIDERS THAT QUALIFY FOR
MEDI CAL REIMBURSEMENT.
AN INCREASE ACCESS IN FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS AND
RURAL HEALTH CENTERS.
COLLEAGUES WE ARE FACING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IN OUR
STATE.
THIS BILL SIMPLY INCREASES
ACCESS AND BRIDGES THE GAPS TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS THAT
OUR STATE SO DESPERATELY NEEDS.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS AREN'T VOTES.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY SIX AB FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ.
A SOMETHING LOW FOR BY SOME THE
MEMBER ARAMBULA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
MR ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND JUST
UNDER THIS ONE OCCASION I MAY
ACTUALLY WANTS TO BE CALLED DR
ARAMBULA JUST BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THIS BILL.
BUT IT'S BECAUSE I SPENT MY
ENTIRE LIFE HAVING PRACTICE
MEDICINE IN A SMALL RURAL TOWN
THAT I AM PRESENTING A BEFORE
HERE TODAY.
WHICH SEEKS TO EXPAND MEDICAL
COVERAGE TO INCOME ELIGIBLE
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS.
SIMPLY PUT THIS BILL REMOVES A
BARRIER TO HELP ACCESS DUE TO
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
UNJUSTLY IMPOSED.
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE WITHOUT
INSURANCE ARE LESS LIKELY TO GET
THE MEDICAL CARE THAT THEY NEED.
THE FEDERAL INSTITUTE OF
MEDICINE PUT IT SUCCINCTLY.
UNINSURED PEOPLE ARE MORE LIKELY
TO RECEIVE TOO LITTLE MEDICAL
CARE AND TO RECEIVE IT TOO LATE.
THEY ARE SICKER AND DIE SOONER.
I HAVE SEEN THIS FIRST HAND.
I WAS ON THE FRONT LINES OF
HEALTH CARE AND FEEL THE URGENCY
TO FIX OUR CURRENT HEALTHCARE
CRISIS.
INSTEAD OF BEING ABLE TO RECEIVE
CARE IN A TIMELY MANNER TO
PREVENT ILLNESSES FROM
DETERIORATING MANY UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ONLY ACCESS CARE
AND EMERGENCY ROOM.
WHERE MANY TIMES PHYSICIANS LIKE
MYSELF ARE NO LONGER ABLE TO
HELP DUE TO THE EXACERBATIONS OF
THEIR ILLNESS?
I'VE SEEN COUNTLESS CASES IN MY
EMERGENCY ROOM IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN THE BREAD BASKET OF
OUR COUNTRY.
WHERE ARE FOUND FARMWORKERS WHO
HELPED TO PRODUCE THE FRUIT AND
VEGETABLES WHICH BILL OUR TABLES
TO SUCH ABUNDANCE?
ARE UNABLE TO DO SO FOR THEIR
OWN FAMILIES DUE TO THEIR DIRE
HEALTH CIRCUMSTANCES.
NOT ONLY IS THIS CURRENT STATE
OF A AFFAIRS DETRIMENTAL TO
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
BUT IT ALSO INCREASES THE DEMAND
ON EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES AND
INCREASES COST IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM OVERALL IN A MANNER
THAT COULD BE PREVENTED.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
FELLOW MEMBERS.
WE INVEST IN THE HEALTH OF OUR
STATE.
WHEN WE INVEST IN HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR LOW INCOME
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS?
WHO ARE A FUNDAMENTAL PART OF
OUR WORK FORCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES?
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
FOUR FOUR I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR BRING IT IS A BILL FOR IT --
ON THIS FLOOR REGARDLESS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S CITIZENSHIP STATUS.
WE MUST.
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SUPPORT
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE HEALTHCARE
IS A HUMAN RIGHTS ARE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM SHOULD DO BETTER.
AND WE CAN DO BETTER BY ENSURING
THE UNDOCUMENTED ARE
UNDOCUMENTED SISTERS AND
BROTHERS WE SEE THE HEALTH
COVERAGE -- THEY DO NEED THEY
NEED THROUGH MEDICARE OUT
CALIFORNIA -- HAS TWO POINT TWO
MILLION UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE. FOR ONLY
LIMITED SCOPE OF MEDIC HOW
DESERVE BETTER MOST UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO THE VISITING THE
HOSPITAL ROOM WHICH ALSO HAS A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THEIR
FINANCIAL STABILITY.
HEALTHCARE COSTS IS BEING -- IN
THE MOUTH OF TENS AND THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS MEMBERS WE COULD DO
BETTER BY PASSING A BEFORE AND
THINK THERE THE THE MEMBER --
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE BEFORE
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER GIVES A MISTER
CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
RISE AS A JOINT AUTHORED THIS
BILL TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE.
UP FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD -- I
MIGHT THE VERY FIRST ISSUE EVER
WORKED ON IN CALIFORNIA WAS IN
THE AFTERMATH OF PROPOSITION ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN WHEN VOTERS IN OUR
STATE IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
SAID -- THAT WE SHOULD NOT ALLOW
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES INTO OUR
EMERGENCY ROOMS.
I THINK SINCE THEN -- THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE STATE HAS SEEN
DIFFERENTLY THEY UNDERSTAND NOT
JUST THE FAIRNESS ISSUE OF THE
IDEA THAT IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE
BORN ON THE WRONG SIDE OF THE
BORDER YOU COULD BE DENIED
HEALTH CARE -- BUT WE ALSO KNOW --
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
HEALTH OF ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS CONTRIBUTE OVER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
STATE AND LOCAL TAXES AND YET
THEY ARE UNJUSTLY EXCLUDED FROM
HEALTH AND SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
THAT THEY HELP TO FUND -- THESE
ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAKE UP ONE
TENTH OF OUR WORK FORCE AND ONE
OUT OF SIX CHILDREN HAVE AN
UNDOCUMENTED PARENTS SO WILD.
ARE CURRENTLY IN OUR STATE WE
ALLOW THOSE CHILDREN JUST
RECEIVE HEALTH CARE WHEN THEIR
PARENTS DON'T RECEIVE HEALTH
CARE IT OBVIOUSLY HAS IMPACTS ON
THEM.
AND OUR FAMILIES AND WITH THAT I
VERY MUCH HOPE THAT EVERYONE CAN
SUPPORT A BEFORE.
THANK YOU MISTER TO MISTER BONTA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I BELIEVE THAT
HEALTHCARE IS A RIGHT NOT A
PRIVILEGE AND IT'S FOR ALL NOT
THE FEW AND A BEFORE HELPS US.
MOVE CLOSER TO WHERE WE WANT TO
BE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE'VE
WE'VE STARTED MOVING SO BOLDLY
WHICH IS TOWARDS UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE OF OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
WE'VE TOLD AN AMAZING STORY.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
OF BEING THE FIRST IN THE NATION
TO ROLL OUT THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT.
AT THE FIRST TO HAVE THE THE
MEDI CAL EXPANSION IN THE
PROCESS COMING MORE MORE
CALIFORNIANS REDUCING THE
UNINSURED POPULATION BY MILLIONS
BUT THE BIGGEST GROUP LEFT.
IS ARE UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIAN
POPULATION OUT WE DID SOMETHING
REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN WE COVER
CHILDREN UNDER UNDOCUMENTED
CHILDREN UNDER MEDI CAL AND THIS
IS THE NEXT STEP IN OUR
PROGRESSION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A BEFORE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA MISS
CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND I
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS TO OUR ATTENTION
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT I JUST
WANTED TO ADD. FOR CLARITY
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
CONTRIBUTE OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR AND STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES AND YOU DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND SO I
THINK WHEN.
FOLKS ARE CONTRIBUTING TO OUR
ECONOMY THEY SHOULD DEFINITELY
BE ABLE TO GO SEE THE DOCTOR AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THIS BODY.
TO PUSH I THANK YOU MISS CARILLO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER MISTER
RANDALL YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I JUST WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES WHO -- ARE FROM
OAKLAND AND SAN FRANCISCO AND
LOS ANGELES WHO WERE ABLE TO
CARRY THIS MEASURE.
WHILE I WAS GONE.
NONE OF US IN THE ASSEMBLY ARE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THINGS
WITHOUT EACH OTHER.
AND JUST IN THAT VEIN WE
SHOULDN'T FORGET THOSE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO STAY IN THE
SHADOWS FOR TOO LONG AND DON'T.
AND ARE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
HEALTH CARE.
HEALTHCARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
AND AS SUCH WE SHOULD GIVE THOSE
WHO ARE IN THE SHADOWS ARE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION THE
DIGNITY THAT THEY DESERVE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THE BEFORE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESERVE
VOTES [inaudible]
CLERK.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY FOUR
KNOWS ELEVEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SEVEN AB
THIRTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND ACTING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED
THAT DUAL ENROLLMENT STUDENTS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO ENTER COLLEGE
PERSISTING COLLEGE TO COMPLETION
AND GRADUATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY INCREASES
ACCESS TO COLLEGE OPPORTUNITIES
STREAMLINES THE PROCESS TO
DEVELOP STRONG PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN K..
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND REMOVES BARRIERS FOR
STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY SB THIRTY
PREVENTS COLLEGE.
AND CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS ARE
SEE CAP PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA FROM EXPIRING AT THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
INSURERS DUAL ENROLLMENT
OPPORTUNITIES REMAIN.
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS WHO MAY
NOT ALREADY BE COLLEGE BOUND.
OR WHO ARE UNDERREPRESENTED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION.
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS FOR
DEVELOPING C. CAP AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN K. TWELVE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
ADDS CONTINUATION HIGH SCHOOLS
TO THE DEFINITION OF STUDENTS
THAT CAN BENEFIT FROM DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS.
ALLOWS UNITS COMPLETED AS PART
OF A C. CAP DUAL ENROLLMENT
PROGRAM TO COUNT TOWARDS
DETERMINING THE REGISTRATION
PRIORITIES AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
ALLOWS HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TO
COMPLETE ONE APPLICATION FOR THE
DURATION OF THEIR ATTENDANCE AT
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS A DUAL
ENROLLMENT STUDENT AND
SIMPLIFIES THE STUDENT.
APPLICATION.
PROHIBITS ASSESSING ANY FEES TO
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND SEE CAP
COURSES INCLUDING STUDENTS IN A
DAHLE CONTINUATION HIGH SCHOOLS.
IN CLOSING WE HAVE SEEN MANY
STUDENTS SUCCESSES SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SEA CAP.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND I
WANT TO CONTINUE TO ASSURE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITS DUAL
ENROLLMENT AS A PERMANENT AND
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGY TO CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND CREATING A SEAMLESS PATHWAYS
FROM HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE ICE FIFTY FIVE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY EIGHT AB
THREE SEVENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTY SIX
BY SOME MEMBER MARK STONE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY STUDENT
LOANS MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
MEMBERS.
STUDENT THAT IS A CRISIS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
ALMOST FOUR MILLION BORROWERS
ARE IN CALIFORNIA WITH A HUNDRED
AND FORTY MILLION DOLLARS ARE
HUNDRED FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF DEBT THAT THEY'RE
CARRYING.
AND WHILE WE WORK TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN GET PEOPLE INTO AND
OUT OF COLLEGE AND OTHER SCHOOLS
WITHOUT THIS CRUSHING THAT WE
HAVE TO LOOK AFTER THOSE WHO
CURRENTLY.
CARRY THAT DEBT.
THAT AMOUNT OF DEBT IS SECOND
ONLY BEHIND HOME MORTGAGES AND
YET WITH HOME MORTGAGES AND
CREDIT CARDS AND MANY OTHER
FORMS OF THAT THERE ARE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE FOR THE
BORROWERS.
NOT TRUE FOR STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS IN FACT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS SERIOUSLY BACKED
OFF ON ANY OF ITS CURRENT
PROGRAMS OR ANY OF ITS PREVIOUS
PROGRAMS.
THAT IT WAS WORKING TOWARDS TO
PROTECT STUDENT BORROWERS THIS
IS A MAJOR.
CRISIS THAT STATES ARE NOW
HAVING TO STEP INTO THAT VOID.
WHAT AB THREE SEVENTY SIX DOES
IS FOR CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
BORROWERS CREATE A PROGRAM WHERE
THE BAR WORDS THAN GET HOLD OF
THEIR RIGHTS HAVE THE STUDENT
LOAN SERVICERS ACTUALLY WORKING
FOR RATHER THAN AGAINST THE
BORROWERS?
SO THAT THEY KNOW WHAT THEIR
ABILITY TO REPAY ARE TO REDUCE
THEIR INTEREST TO REDUCE THAT
OBLIGATION MEMBERS THIS IS A
STEP FORWARD THAT WE CAN TAKE TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS TO PROTECT
ALMOST FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH THIS
THAT TAKING THAT MONEY OUT OF
THE ECONOMY TAKING THEIR
PRODUCTIVITY OUT OF THE ECONOMY
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO STEP
UP AND PROTECT THIS CLASS OF
BORROWERS WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU MISTER STONE MUSLIM ON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SEVEN SIX THIS BILL STRENGTHENS
THE PROTECTIONS FOR STUDENT LOAN
BARS BY REQUIRING STUDENT LOAN
SERVICERS. TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION AND SERVICES THAT
ARE IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
STUDENT BARS.
THE FEDERAL CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU REPORT THAT
TODAY THERE IS ONE POINT THREE
TRILLION DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN
DEBT NATIONWIDE WITH OVER A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR BILLION
OF THAT DAY IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THE LATE NINETEEN SIXTIES WE
SAW AN INCREASE IN TUITION.
THIS INCREASE IN TUITION AND
FEES WAS ACCOMPANIED BY EVER
INCREASING INCREASING COST OF
HOUSING MEALS BOOKS AND SUPPLIES.
IN ORDER TO MANAGE THE COST OF
COLLEGE SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
STUDENTS.
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS STUDENTS
TURNED TO STUDENT LOANS TO
ACHIEVE THEIR COLLEGE EDUCATION
GOALS STUDENT LOAN SERVICERS ARE
MEANT TO HELP STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS MANAGE STUDENT DEBT.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS HAS NOT
ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE THIS BILL
PUTS IN PLACE COMMONSENSE
MEASURES THAT REQUIRE SERVICES
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION AND
SERVICES THAT ARE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF STUDENT BARS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL PROVIDES A
REMEDY FOR BORROWS THAT DO NOT
RECEIVE APPROPRIATE PROGRAM
INFORMATION AS REQUIRED BY LAW.
EVERY TIME A STUDENT BORROWER IS
FINANCIALLY HARM BY IN NON
PERFORMING LEARN SERVICE ARE.
WE ARE ALL AREN'T IT IS
DIFFICULT ENOUGH WORKING YOUR
WAY THROUGH COLLEGE WITHOUT
HAVING A STUDENT LOAN SERVICER
THAT IS MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
MAKING MONEY OFF STUDENT BARS.
BEEN HELPING STUDENTS MANAGE
THEIR DEBT AND BECOME PRODUCTIVE
AND CREATIVE MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY MEMBERS I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR IT AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS THE MON THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I TO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SEVENTY SIX AND THE
CREATION OF THE STUDENT BORROWER
BILL OF RIGHTS AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR MONTEREY
BAY.
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD AND FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON TACKLING THE STUDENT DEBT
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT IS A CRISIS AS THE AUTHOR
NOTED.
THERE ARE ALMOST FOUR MILLION.
BORROWERS IN CALIFORNIA HER
STRUGGLING TODAY WITH STUDENT
DEBT FOR THESE BORROWERS.
STUDENT AT CAST A SHADOW OVER
EVERY ASPECT OF THEIR LIVES FROM
DECIDING WHETHER THEY CAN START
A FAMILY.
WHAT JOB THEY CAN PURSUE CAN A
SAFE RETIREMENT CAN THEY BUY A
HOME THE RIPPLE EFFECTS OF THOSE
DECISIONS ARE BEING FELT ALL
ACROSS THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY?
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY SIX AND
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
TACKLING THIS ISSUE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISS PETRI NORRIS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
STONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I FIGURED I WOULD APPRECIATE HI
MY COLLEAGUES ARE CALLING TO WHO
SPOKE ON THIS BILL THIS IS A
CRITICAL SITUATION FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS THE AS WE TRY TO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF THAT DEBT THAT'S
OUT THERE.
THIS WILL NOT REDUCE THE DEBT
PER SE OTHER THAN BY GIVING THAT
STUDENT BORROWERS THE TOOLS TO
REDUCE THEIR INTEREST AND THEIR
OBLIGATIONS OVER TIME.
SOME OF THE TRICKS THAT THE THAT
THE STUDENT LOAN SERVICERS DO IS.
TO PUT THE THE LOAN IN ABEYANCE
THEREBY CREATING MORE INTEREST
FOR THAT STUDENT TO PAY DOWN
OVER A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME.
IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT REDUCING
THAT IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
HELPING THESE INDIVIDUALS OUT
THESE BARS OUT ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A TOOL THAT WILL GIVE
THEM THAT BENEFIT I ASK FOR YOUR
EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER STAND THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR ALL.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY ONE KNOWS
TENNIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE AB FOR
SEVENTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVENTEEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
AGRICULTURE.
MR ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY A PRESENT ON AB
FOR SEVENTEEN THE AGRICULTURAL
AND WORLD PROSPERITY ACT.
THE NEEDS OF RURAL CALIFORNIA
ARE UNIQUE.
WITH HIGH POVERTY AND
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES OUR
COMMUNITIES OFTEN LACK ACCESS TO
RESOURCES CAPITAL AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE NECESSARY.
WE ALSO KNOW THESE AREAS ARE
HOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL POWERHOUSE
PRODUCTION.
THESE COMMUNITIES ECONOMIES
DEPEND ON THEIR WORKING LANDS.
THEIR SUCCESS IS PREDICATED ON
AGRICULTURAL SUCCESS.
AB FOR SEVENTEEN WOULD SUPPORT
THESE ECONOMIES BY EMPOWERING
THE SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. TO ESTABLISH A
DEDICATED POSITION TO HELP
CALIFORNIA'S RURAL
AGRICULTURALLY BASED ECONOMIES
THRIVE.
THIS POSITION COULD ENABLE THE
DEPARTMENT TO HELP THESE
ECONOMIES IDENTIFY NEEDS AND
FORM PARTNERSHIPS.
ASSESS LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
RESOURCES PREPARE REPORTS AND
REVIEW ECONOMIC DATA.
ALL IN AN EFFORT TO ENHANCE THE
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE FOR
RURAL AGRICULTURAL ECONOMIES.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES TODAY ON AB.
FOR SEVENTEEN SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY ONE KNOWS
ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY AB FOR
TWENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR TWENTY THREE
ACTUALLY THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT.
TO GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER -- EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY THREE WILL FORM THE CITY
GO AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT BOARD TO INCREASE THE
PARTICIPATION ON THE BOARD AS
WELL AS THEIR PROGRAM
TRANSPARENCY.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
DIVERSE COALITION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED ABOUT
THIS TAKES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FORTY ONE KNOWS A
LEVIN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE ONE THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME LEGAL FOR NINETY THREE
BY SOME THE MEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO TEACHERS
MR GLORIA YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB FOR NINETY THREE WILL CREATE
A MORE SUPPORTIVE AND SAFE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LGBT Q. STUDENTS BY
PROVIDING TEACHERS WITH THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO SUPPORT.
OUR YOUTH BOTH AT SCHOOL AND IN
THEIR COMMUNITY.
I THINK MEMBERS YOU KNOW THAT
MANY OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE DO NOT
ALWAYS HAVE THE BEST OUTCOMES --
EDUCATIONALLY BECAUSE OF THE
BULLYING AND HARRASSMENT TODAY
EXPERIENCE IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
I'LL SHARE PERSONALLY THAT I
ACTUALLY DIDN'T ATTEND A
TRADITIONAL JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL I
BECAUSE I DON'T FEEL SAFE AND MY
HIGH SCHOOL I WAS BULLIED AND
HARASSED TO THE POINT THAT I WAS
ACTUALLY HOME SCHOOL FOR TWO
YEARS.
DURING THOSE CRITICAL YEARS OF
MY EDUCATION I WAS JUST LUCKY
THAT APPARENTLY WAS WILLING TO
LET ME DO THAT.
SO MANY OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE FACE
THAT KIND OF DISCRIMINATION I
KIND OF HARASSMENT THAT KIND OF
PAIN ON A DAILY BASIS I CAN TELL
YOU MEMBERS MY ENTIRE LIFE
EXPERIENCE.
OF ALL THE TIME THIS HAPPENED TO
ME ONLY ONE TEACHER EVER DID
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
IS ABOUT GIVING THOSE TEACHERS
WHO I BELIEVE CARED ABOUT MY
EDUCATION EDUCATION OF SO MANY
OTHER CALIFORNIA THE TOOLS TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS WHAT CAN BE A
DELICATE AND SENSITIVE SITUATION.
AMONG THE MANY OTHER THINGS AND
MANDATE HAVE BEEN IN A CLASSROOM
GIVE THEM THE TRAINING IN THE
RESOURCES TO ALLOW THEM TO BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE TO INTERVENE TO
STOP THE BILLING HARASSMENT OF
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT AGAIN
MEMBERS I WANNA REMIND YOU.
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO MISS
SCHOOL BECAUSE THESE LGBT Q.
STUDENTS ARE BULLIED IN OUR
CLASSROOMS TWICE AS LIKELY TO
SAY THEY HAVE NO INTENTIONS OF
PURSUING HIGHER EDUCATION.
THEY ABSOLUTELY HAVE LOWER GRADE
POINT AVERAGES ON OCCASION
BECAUSE OF THIS BEHAVIOR MEMBERS
IN YOUR HANDS THIS AFTERNOON TO
CHANGE THIS BY PASSING THIS BILL
IN THE COURSE MONEY BUDGET
APPROPRIATION FOR IT.
SO THAT WE CAN GIVE OUR KIDS A
FIGHTING CHANCE TO BE ABLE TO
STAY IN THE CLASSROOM GET THE
EDUCATION AND CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
SOCIETY MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR
POSITIVE VOTE ON A. B..
FOUR NINETY THREE THANK YOU
MISTER GLORIA SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
TWO NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO A. B.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY
EIGHT BASED ON THE NUMBER BLOOM
IN OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
MR BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE SANTA MONICA
BAY RESTORATION COMMISSION IS A
NON REGULATORY STATE ENTITY THAT
WAS ENACTED BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO TASKED WITH
COORDINATING FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL EFFORTS TO RESTORE AND
ENHANCE SANTA MONICA BAY AND
IT'S WATERSHED.
I HAD THE HONOR OF SERVING --
FROM ITS FORMATION AS A
COMMISSIONER AND TO FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS OF MY TIME ON THE
SANTA MONICA CITY COUNCIL AS
CHAIR OF THE BAY RESTORATION
COMMISSION.
AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN UPDATES THE
STATUTES GOVERNING THE
COMMISSION BY REPLACING THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES WE ARE ON
A. B..
FIVE NINETY EIGHT WATCH ME PULL
A RABBIT OUT OF MY HAT
[inaudible]
NICE.
ALLOW ME TO SWITCH GEARS MADAM
SPEAKER IN COURT THANK YOU FOR
THE CORRECTION.
A CHILD'S ABILITY TO HERS TO BE
TO HEAR -- LIKE MINE IT SHOULD
NOT BE DETERMINED BY THEIR
FAMILY INCOME.
YET HERE IN CALIFORNIA THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES HAVE TO PAY FOR
THEIR CHILD'S HEARING AIDS OUT
OF POCKET OR SIMPLY HAVE TO
FOREGO THEM -- FOR ATOGETHER.
AB FIVE NINETY EIGHT ADDRESSES
THIS GAP IN COVERAGE BY
REQUIRING HEALTH CARE SERVICE
PLANS AND HEALTH INSURANCE
POLICIES. TO INCLUDE COVERAGE
FOR CHAIR IN CHILDREN'S HEARING
AIDS.
COVERAGE INCLUDES THE INITIAL
HEARING ASSESSMENT NEW HEARING
AIDS AT LEAST EVERY FOUR YEARS
NEW EAR MOLDS AND A NEW HEARING
AID IF THE EXISTING ONE IS NO
LONGER WORKING.
THE COST OF A HEARING AID IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
PARENTS OBTAINING.
AFTER HEARING AIDS AS THESE
DEVICES CAN COST UP TO SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A PAIR AND
GROWING CHILDREN NEED THESE
DEVICES.
REPLACED FREQUENTLY AB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT WILL ENSURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR
BACKGROUND HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR HEARING AIDS.
AND HEARING AID SERVICES AND
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
YES THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE A PROUD CO AUTHOR
OF THIS LEGISLATION AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD -- THIS IS THIS IS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR DEAF AND HARD
OF HEARING -- COMMUNITIES.
THEY DON'T HAVE A CHOICE.
NOW THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THEY
THEY NEED IS A NECESSITY.
AND ALSO THE OTHER THING TO
UNDERSTAND IS IT.
STE YOU KNOW SOME MIGHT BE
TRYING TO PUSH COCHLEAR IMPLANTS
WELL NOT ALL IN THE DEAF
COMMUNITY.
I BELIEVE THAT THAT IS THE
ANSWER AND THERE IS A VERY
STRONG DEAF CULTURE -- ED THAT
BELIEVES IT THEY WERE THEY WERE
BORN DEAF AND THEY'RE PROUD OF
OF WHO THEY ARE -- AND SO KIND
OF PUSHING PEOPLE TO DO THINGS
THAT [inaudible]
ARE AGAINST.
WHO THEY ARE AS A PERSON IN?
AND THEIR IDENTITY IS IS ALSO AN
ISSUE HERE AND SO ALLOWING.
HEARING AIDS TO BE ABSOLUTELY
COVERED UNDER HEALTH PLANS AS A
GOOD MEASURE AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS OF THIS BILL
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
BLOOM WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YES THANK YOU FROM THE US
SUPPORT ACROSS THE AISLE THIS.
HAS BEEN A BIPARTISAN BILL FROM
THE OUTSET AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL NUMBERS NOTED AS OUR DEVOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
COACH.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
APPROACH THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE AND FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY FIVE AB SIX SIXTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY THREE BY
SELLING MEMBER CUNNINGHAM AND
ACTUALLY TO PROSTITUTION.
SIR CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
WE ALL KNOW WE'RE FIGHTING
WORLDWIDE BATTLE AGAINST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
IT'S THE FASTEST GROWING CRIME
IN THE WORLD IT'S A HUNDRED AND
FORTY BILLION DOLLAR ENTERPRISE.
WHAT WE'RE ALSO DEALING WITH IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE EROSION OF THE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION FUND?
OUT OF WHICH VICTIMS OF
TRAFFICKING CAN.
OBTAIN SOME SUPPORT TO REBUILD
THEIR LIVES WERE TALKING ABOUT
COUNSELING WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RELOCATION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ANY CHANCE.
OF REBUILDING THEIR LIVES IN THE
WORLD AFTER THEY WERE ABUSED.
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS
PROVIDE A PERMANENT COUNTY LEVEL
FUNDING SOURCE BY TAKING FINES
PAID BY THOSE CONVICTED OF
SOLICITATION?
AND DIRECTING THOSE FINES TO THE
COUNTY 75% OF WHICH WILL BE
RETAIN SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
PURPOSE.
OF HELPING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS THIS WILL PUT OUR
COUNTIES.
ON A SUSTAINABLE FOOTING.
IN ORDER TO HELP VICTIMS OF
TRAFFICKING.
AND EASE THE BURDEN THAT'S ON
THE STATE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
FUND -- I'M PROUD TO SAY THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
SO FAR -- PLEASE AT PLEASE VOTE
AYE THANKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTERS.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THAT I SIXTEEN NOES
THREE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
I ONE THIRTY SIX AB SIX SEVENTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY THREE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER CARILLO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT.
THIS CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY THREE
A BILL THAT PROVIDES MORE
EFFECTIVE REMEDIES FOR WORKERS
WHO ARE NOT PAID THEIR WAGES ON
TIME.
RECEIVING YOUR PAYCHECK ON TIME
IS THE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
YET FAR TOO OFTEN WORKERS
ESPECIALLY IN LOW WAGE
INDUSTRIES WAIT DAYS WEEKS OR
EVEN MONTHS. FOR THEIR HARD
EARNED WAGES THIS YEAR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ISSUED THE LARGEST
CITATION IN STATE HISTORY.
FINDING A CONSTRUCTION COMPANY
NEARLY TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR REPEATED WAIT THAT
VIOLATIONS WHICH LEFT OVER ONE
THOUSAND WORKERS WAITING WEEKS
OR MONTHS FOR THEIR PAYCHECK.
UNDER CURRENT LAW EMPLOYEES HAVE
NO DIRECT RECOURSE WHEN THEY ARE
NOT PAID ON TIME.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO RECOVER A
PENALTY WHEN WAGES ARE NOT PAID
ON TIME BUT ACCORDING TO THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER.
THIS PENALTY IS OFTEN NOT
COLLECTED EVEN IF THE PENALTIES
WERE TO BE COLLECTED BY THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER THE PENALTIES
GO TO THE STATE AND NOT THE
WORKER.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE
PENALTY IS ASSESSING THE WORKERS
ARE PROVIDED WITH SOME RELIEF
WHEN EMPLOYERS.
DO NOT PAY THEM ON TIME.
UNDER AB SIX SEVENTY THREE THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER OR THE WORKER
WILL BE ABLE TO RECOVER THE
EXISTING PENALTY THROUGH A
HEARING.
BEFORE THE LABOR COMMISSIONER IF
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER RECOVERED
THE PENALTY AND ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTION.
THAT PENALTY WILL BE PAID.
AFFECTED TO THE UP I'M SORRY
THAT PENALTY WILL BE PAID TO THE
AFFECTED EMPLOYEE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL WILL
HELP BRING THE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT OF SIMPLY GETTING A
PAYCHECK ON TIME [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THE
THIRD TO BE PAID ON TIME AND
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE TO ME
COURSE AND REMEDIES THE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS FOR TONIGHT
THIS BASIC RIGHT.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED HAS
RECENTLY BEEN AMENDED TO REMOVE
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION AND
NOW HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
COACH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTERS THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY TWO KNOWS FOURTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEMS ONE THIRTY SEVEN AND ONE
THIRTY EIGHT FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY NINE AB SEVEN SIXTY FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIXTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA.
MISTER BROWN TO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY
FOUR AT THESE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
THAT AMUSEMENT PARKS SPORTS
STADIUMS AND OTHER ATTRACTIONS.
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS BE ADOPTED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO NAME.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT A BACK TO
FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY AB SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER WHAT'S IN
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE.
IS WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
SO WHEN I WAS IN MY EARLY
THIRTIES I WAS HELPING TO
REELECT PRESIDENT OBAMA WORKING
ABOUT A HUNDRED HOURS A WEEK I
WAS -- YOUNG I DIDN'T KNOW WHEN
OR IF I WANTED TO HAVE A FAMILY.
BUT I WENT TO THE DOCTOR TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT MY FERTILITY
LOOKS LIKE.
AND THAT'S WHEN I GOT THE
UNFORTUNATE NEWS THAT I HAD A
LOW FOLLICLE COUNT.
AND MY DOCTOR SAID YOU SHOULD
FREEZE YOUR EGGS IF YOU WANT TO
HAVE CHILDREN.
SO I WAS LUCKY I LIVED IN
ILLINOIS THE TIME AND ILLINOIS
REQUIRES THREE COVERS OF IVF
COVERAGE FOR FOLKS THAT ARE
DIAGNOSED WITH.
A VERY DYSFUNCTION WHICH IS WHAT
I HAD SO MY MY MY A FREEZING WAS
COVERED.
AND THAT'S NOT THE CASE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IVF IS EXPLICITLY EXCLUDED FOR
HEALTH INSURANCE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW MA'AM MANY
OF YOU I'M SURE HAVE PEOPLE IN
YOUR COMMUNITY MAYBE FRIENDS
FAMILY MAYBE YOURSELF THAT HAVE
HAD TO UNDERGO IVF.
AND THIS CAN BE THIRTY FORTY
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THAT'S PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE
FOR MANY FAMILIES.
AND A FOURTEEN STATES IN THIS
COUNTRY CAN GET I'VE YOU HAVE
COVERED UNDER INSURANCE I KNOW
THAT WE CAN DO IT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO MY BILL THE GOAL OF MY
BILLS TO DO EXACTLY JUST THAT.
IT'S CURRENTLY IN INTENT BILL
IT'S GOING TO GO TO THE SENATE
BUT I WANT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
THAT WE CAN GET IVF COVERED FOR
ALL FAMILIES LGBT FAMILIES.
LOW INCOME FAMILIES SO THE
PEOPLE WHEN THEY WANT TO HAVE
CHILDREN THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DO IT.
AND I THINK THAT WE CAN DO IT
HERE IN THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY OF THIS COUNTRY.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU MRS WHERE X. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS FIVE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY ONE AB SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO VOTER EDUCATION.
MS GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE WILL HELP EQUIP OUR YOUNG
ADULTS TO BECOME.
MORE ENGAGED AT THE BALLOT BOX --
BY REQUIRING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IMPLEMENT VOTER EDUCATION
PROGRAM MEAN FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THE REALITY IS MOST OF
US PROBABLY LEARNED HOW TO VOTE
FROM OUR PARENTS MAYBE WE WENT
WITH THEM TO THE POLLS.
BUT TODAY'S STUDENTS
OVERWHELMINGLY DON'T HAVE
PARENTS WHO VOTED OR ELIGIBLE TO
VOTE SO WHILE WE EXPAND ACCESS
AND REMOVE BARRIERS WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS
OF VOTING.
IT CAN BE COMPLICATED IT CAN BE
SCARY AND IT CAN BE TAUGHT VERY
QUICKLY IN AN UNBIASED WAY
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEKING TO DO
HERE TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS TENNIS MEASURE
PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS
ONE FORTY THREE AND ONE FORTY
FOUR FILE ITEM ONE FORTY FIVE AB
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER GIPSON AND
ACTUALLY THE FIRE ARMS MAKE AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
SIR GIPSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT AB.
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE WHICH SEEKS
TO CLOSE THE GHOST GUN LOOPHOLE
BY REQUIRING THE STATE A
BACKGROUND CHECK FOR PURCHASERS
OF ON FINISH FRAMES AND
RECEIVERS AND REQUIRE ALL
PURCHASERS -- TAKE -- TAKE PLACE
THROUGH A LICENSED GUN DEALER
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES BACKGROUND
CHECKS FOR BOTH THE GUN SALES
AND AMMUNITION YET IS SILENT ON
THE TREATMENT OF OUR ARMED PARTS.
THIS BILL INTENDS TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY BY PREVENTING
CRIMINALS AND THOSE WHO
OTHERWISE SHOULD NOT POSSESS FAR
ARMS FROM GAINING ACCESS WHILE
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF GUN
OWNERS.
I AM HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE IS A FULL
SUPPORT AS BEEN WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE OF TO MAKE THIS BILL BUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
ON A. B.. EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER OF THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THIS TAKES.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE -- ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL.
MR GIVE SOME OF THE CALL.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SIX WE PASS
TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
SEVEN AB NINE FORTY TO THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY WILL NINE
FORTY TO BUY SOMETHING MEMBER
WEBER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
HEALTH RASH.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER YES MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT YOU AB NINE FOUR TWO
ACCESS TO SAFE FOOD CHOICES AND
FOOD.
AND FOOD SECURITY THIS IS
SIMILAR TO THE OTHER BILL THAT
FOCUSED ON COLLEGE STUDENT THIS
TO EXPAND CALPERS PROGRAMS IN
CONJUNCTION THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES TO FURTHER
INCREASE.
FOOD ACCESS FOOD SECURITY AND
FOOD CHOICES FOR HOMELESS
DISABLED AND ELOK ELDERLY
RECIPIENTS OF CALIFORNIA'S.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND ALL
OF US AND NONE OF US.
THE LAWS WERE TO FOUNDATION AND
MOM'S RISING IN ADDITION IS
SUPPORTED BY A MULTITUDE OF FOOD
BANKS AND ADVOCACY GROUPS ARE
CALIFORNIA.
AB NINE FOUR THREE HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLIED VOTE ICE FIFTY FOUR NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY EIGHT AB NINE FIFTY
FOR THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
WILL NINE FIFTY FOUR BY FAMILY
MEMBER WOULD AND ACTUALLY THE
DENTAL SERVICES.
MISTER WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
PROVIDER NETWORK LEASING
ARRANGEMENTS ARE PRESENTING
NUMEROUS PROBLEMS FOR DENTISTS
AND THEIR PATIENTS THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO FIX THOSE PROBLEMS.
CURRENTLY THE ENTITIES THAT
LEASE OR PURCHASE THESE PROVIDER
NETWORKS HAVE LIMITED
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE TRANSPARENT.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR DENNIS TO
KNOW WHICH FEE SCHEDULES ARE IN
EFFECT FOR WHICH PATIENTS
BECAUSE DENNIS ARE SENSITIVE TO
THE PRICE CONCERNS THEIR
PATIENTS HAVE.
THEY NEED THIS TRANSPARENCY TO
BE ABLE TO CLEARLY DISCUSS
VARIOUS TREATMENT OPTIONS AND
ACCURATE OUT OF POCKET COSTS FOR
THEM.
THIS BILL FOR IT WOULD ALLOW FOR
EXAMPLE DENTAL PLANS TO GRANT
THIRD PARTY ACCESS TO PROVIDER
NETWORK SO THE DENNIS CAN HAVE
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHETHER OR
NOT TO PARTICIPATE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WOODS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
APPROACH.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY THREE AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ. ONE FORTY ASSEMBLY WILL
EIGHT THIRTY ONE BY SOME OVER
GRAYSON ACTING HOUSING.
MR GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE IS A SIMPLE MEASURE
TO ADD TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO AGE CD'S STUDY.
ON THE MITIGATION FEE ACT WHICH
IS DUE OUT NEXT MONTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE SUCH.
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY SIX NOW
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING BACK. TO FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY NINE AB NINE SIXTY THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY WILL
NINE SIXTY BY SOMETHING MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS ACTUALLY
TO CAL WORKS MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED OKAY IN THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES TEMPORARY
HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO HOMELESS
FAMILIES RECEIVING AID.
THROUGH THE COW WORKS PROGRAM
FOR UP TO SIXTEEN CONSECUTIVE
NIGHTS AND HOTEL MOTEL OR
COMMERCIAL ESTABLISHMENT.
AB NINE SIXTY WILL REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE SIXTEEN
DAYS BE CONSECUTIVE AND WILL
THAT AND THAT'S ELIMINATED
DISINCENTIVE TO REFUSE OR
INTERRUPT TEMPORARY HOUSING
ASSISTANCE.
WILL ALSO ALLOW PERMANENT
HOUSING ASSISTANCE BE USED
TOWARDS SHARED HOUSING SETTINGS
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I FIFTY THREE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY AB NINE
SIXTY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME LEGAL NINE SIXTY THREE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
THIS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB
NINE SIXTY THREE THE STUDENT
VOTER AND CIVIC.
EMPOWERMENT ACT THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH THE ROLE THAT THE
CIVIC AND VOTER EMPOWERMENT
COORDINATOR ON THE CAMPUSES OF
OUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES.
I PROGRAMS LIKE THESE THAT HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED I'M IN SCHOOL SUCH
AS UCLA HAD PROVEN TO INCREASE.
VOTER PARTICIPATION AND CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT ON CAMPUS.
I AT SIMILAR TO THE BILL
INTRODUCED BY MY COLLEAGUE MS
GONZALEZ FROM SAN DIEGO.
WHAT WE NEED ALL ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS AN
ENGAGED AN INFORMED ELECTORATE
AND WE HAVE THREE POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS ON OUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGE CAMPUSES?
AT THESE CAMPUSES MUST PLAY A
PIVOTAL ROLE IN COURT IN
ENCOURAGING CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND
INVOLVING YOUNG ADULTS IN OUR
DEMOCRACY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE IT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS PETER NORRIS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS FIVE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE A. B.
NINE SEVENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY
ONE BY SOME OF THE NUMBER SALAS
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTS.
MR SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I PRESENTS ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE SEVENTY ONE WHICH WILL STAB
WISH ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
CONTRACTORS FOR STATE IT
PROJECTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE ICE FIFTY EIGHT
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO AB NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SOME THE MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AND OTHERS IN A CLINICAL WORKS
MR RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THAT THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE EIGHT SEVEN
WHAT EXTEND THE CAL WORKS
SPECIAL NEEDS SUPPLEMENT TO
FAMILIES WITH A CHILD WAS TESTED
POSITIVE FOR LEAD EXPOSURE.
HAS SPECIAL -- THE DIETARY NEEDS
OR LACKS ACT ACCESS TO CLEAN
WATER.
AS WE ALL KNOW FAMILIES LIVING
IN DEEP POVERTY FACE MANY
CHALLENGES ONE OF WHICH IS
RELATED TO THEIR PERSONAL HEALTH.
OUR PORTS FAMILIES IN THIS STATE
BASED HEALTH RISK RELATED TO
LEAD EXPOSURE AND A LACK OF
ACCESS TO CLEAN AND SAFE WATER --
THEY FACE HIGH RATES OF THE DIET
RELATED ILLNESS WHICH IS
ASSOCIATE WITH A LACK OF ACCESS
TO HEALTHY FOODS.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S POOREST
FAMILIES RECEIVE THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO ADDRESS SPECIAL
FOOD NEEDS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
IT'LL GO A VERY LONG WAY TO
TREAT ILLNESS AND IMPROVE THE
HEALTH OF OUR POOREST AND MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
THANK YOU MAN.
THANK YOU MYSTERY THE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DISCARD VOTES.
WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND FILE
ITEMS ONE FIFTY THREE AND ONE
FIFTY FOUR MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY FIVE AB TEN OH SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN OH SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT.
MISTER JONES ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM SPEAKER AB
TEN OH SEVEN HELPS OUR STATE
EMPLOYEES.
BY PROVIDING CERTAINTY IN THE
DISCIPLINARY TIME WHY IS THIS
THE LAW ALLOWS UP TO THREE YEARS
TO COMPLETE AN INVESTIGATION
THAT MAY RESULT IN EMPLOYEE
DISCIPLINE.
THIS MEANS THAT A STATE EMPLOYEE
REGARDLESS WHETHER OR NOT THEY
COMMITTED IN IT INAPPROPRIATE
ACT MUST PUT THEIR CAREER ON
HOLD FOR UP TO THREE YEARS THEY
CANNOT REQUEST THE REYES.
REQUEST TO TRANSFER A BE PUT
FORWARD FOR PROMOTION
FURTHERMORE IN CASES WHERE AN
IMPROPER ACTION HAS OCCURRED IT
CAN TAKE UP TO THREE YEARS
BEFORE EMPLOYEES EVEN DISCIPLINE.
ALLOWING THEM TO REPEAT EVERY
HAVER WITHOUT EMPLOYEE TO ONE
YEAR PROVIDES EMPLOYEES
CERTAINTY AND ALLOW FOR MORE
TIMELY CORRECTIVE ACTION.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSEWHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO COACH.
THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A
MEASURE REQUIRES
FORTY ONE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
CHOIRS [inaudible]
FORTY ONE YEAH.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE AYES FORTY FIVE NO
SEVENTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY IN FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY SIX FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY SEVEN AB TEN THIRTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
A SOMETHING WILL TEN THIRTY ONE
BY SOME LIMóN IS AREA AND
OTHERS AND THAT'S LIKE ALCOHOL
AND DRUG TREATMENT.
MISTER IS THERE IN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TEN
THIRTY ONE WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO DEVELOP REGULATIONS
FOR A COMPREHENSIVE CONTINUUM OF
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER CARE FOR
YOUTH UNDER AGE.
TWENTY ONE IT WOULD ALSO ENABLE
COUNTIES AND PROVIDERS. TO
PROPERLY CLAIM AND BILL FOUR EPS
TD ENTITLEMENT SERVICES UNDER
DRUG MEDI CAL BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT TO ESTABLISH BILLING
CODES WERE COVERED.
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE OF DRUGS
SERVICES UNDER THE PST THE
BENEFIT.
SINCE THERE IS A FEDERAL MATCH
FOR EP STD THE ABILITY TO BILL
FOR THESE SERVICES WOULD DRAW
DOWN FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR YOUTH
TREATMENT.
ESTABLISHING STATEWIDE STANDARDS
AND BILLING CODES WILL BE OF A A
VALUABLE TOOL FOR YOUTH
TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
AB TEN THIRTY ONE HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
A RESPECTFULLY ASK VERY AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED.
HOME MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
ROADS.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY EIGHT
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHTY BE
TEN THIRTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY
THREE BY SOMETHING MEMBER COOPER
AND ACTUALLY STATE EMPLOYMENT.
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B. TEN TO
THIRTY THREE WAS SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE OFFERED
EMPLOYMENT.
BY STATE AGENCY PROVIDING
EXPLANATION OF THE BENEFITS THAT
A COMPANY STATE CIVIL SERVICE IS
TO PLACE AN EMPLOYEE MUST
RECEIVE A WRITTEN.
MINERALIZATION DOCUMENT
ACKNOWLEDGING THEY RECEIVE THESE
MATERIAL BEFORE ACCEPTING
APPOINTMENT.
THIS BILL RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES
AND BIPARTISAN SUPPORT A
COMMITTEE ARE SPECIALLY ASTRI
RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
COACH.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
VOTES.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE ICE FIFTY NINE
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY NINE AB TEN
SIXTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AN ACTUAL
INDIVIDUALS.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TO PRESENT AB TEN SIXTY
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY.
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM HAS LONG STRUGGLED WITH
THE BEST WAY TO INCLUDE ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF A
CHILD'S NEEDS WHEN MAKING A
DECISION.
IT'S BEEN ESPECIALLY DIFFICULT
TO ENSURE THAT FOSTER YOUTH
THEMSELVES HAVE A REAL VOICE IN
THE PROCESS.
AB EIGHT TEN SIXTY EIGHT
STRENGTHENS THE CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAM PROCESS BY CREATING NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOWS FOR THE USE
OF A NEUTRAL FACILITATOR WHEN
REQUESTED.
AND ENSURES THAT THE EDUCATIONAL
RIGHTS HOLDER IS INCLUDED IN
PLACEMENT DECISIONS THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND ON BEHALF OF MR
COOLEY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
VOTES.
WORK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE ICE FIFTY FIVE KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
I'M PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE THE PURPLE
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE VOTERS.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE.
AYE AYES FORTY TWO NO SIX THIS
MEASURE PASSES
.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY AB TEN
SEVENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
A SOME PEOPLE TEND SEVENTY FIVE
BY SOME THE NUMBER HOLDEN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING ONE
OF THE WORST TEACHER SHORTAGES
IN HISTORY.
WE ALL KNOW THERE IS A SEVERE
SHORTAGE OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS BUT WHAT MIGHT BE LESS
KNOWN.
THAT IS THERE IS A SHORTAGE OF
SERIOUS SHORTAGE OF SPEECH AND
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGISTS OR SO PEAS.
SO PEAS PROVIDE MANY SERVICES IN
A STUDENTS INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLAN.
OR I EP SPEECH AND LANGUAGE IS
ONE OF THE LARGEST DISABILITIES
AND STUDENTS AND IS GROWING EACH
YEAR.
DO THE STORAGE AND SO PEAS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE FORCED TO
CONTRACT WITH SPECIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES.
AND PAY HIGHER RATES.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTY FIVE
WOULD INCREASE THE NUMBER OF SO
P. SLOTS AT THE S. C. ISSUES. TO
MEET THE GROWING DEMAND SO PEAS
AND OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER.
THANK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER MR HOLDEN WAS HIDING YOUR
MICROPHONE.
I APOLOGIZE TO MY ESTEEMED AND
AND RATHER VERTICAL COLLEAGUES
AND I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT TO THIS
FLOOR AND THE SHORTAGE OF SLP IS
HAS BEEN AN ONGOING CHALLENGE.
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
PROVISION OF SPECIAL SUPPORT
SERVICES -- ACROSS THIS STATE
THIS MEASURE HELPS US GET PART
OF THE WAY IN ADDRESSING -- NOT
ONLY A GOAL TO PROVIDE EVERY
STUDENT WITH SUPPORT OF SERVICES
THEY NEED BUT TO SAVE OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CONSIDERABLE RESOURCES
SO I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE OUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MISS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER MISTER HOLDEN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS I WROTE THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND
VIOLATE ONE SIXTY ONE FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY TWO AB TEN NINETY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN NINETY SEVEN
BY FAMILY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER YES THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS BILL IS
MEANT TO BEGIN A CONVERSATION
AROUND CREDIT RECOVERY CLASSES
IN CALIFORNIA.
REALLY PROGRAMS LET'S STUDENTS
WHO FAIL A CLASS RECOVER CREDIT
VIA ABBREVIATED MAKE UP COURSES.
DONE WELL CREDIT RECOVERY
PROGRAMS PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH
LEGITIMATE SECOND CHANCE TO
GRADUATE ON TIME [inaudible]
BUT SOME.
BUT SOME PARTICULARLY HIGH
VOLUME PROGRAMS HAVE QUALITY
CONTROL PROBLEMS THAT CREATE A
SECOND TRACK TO GRADUATION THAT
A ROAD SCHOOL CULTURES THE
LORD'S EXPECTATIONS PARTICULARLY
FOR DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY TOO LITTLE IS
KNOWN ACROSS THE NATION AND AND
AND IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT THE
QUALITY OF THESE PROGRAMS.
WE SHOULD INCREASE ATTENTION TO
THESE RAPIDLY EXPANDING PROGRAMS
TO ENSURE.
THEY ARE HELPING NOT HARMING
STUDENTS STRUGGLING TO GRADUATE.
CURRENTLY CD COLLECTS NO DOUBT --
ON CREDIT RECOVERY PROGRAMS AND
THERE IS NO DEFINITION OR
REGULATION OF CREDIT RECOVERY
AND STATUTES.
AB TEN NINETY SEVEN IS A
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE THAT
DIRECTS CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. TO REPORT ON THE USE
OF CREDIT RECORD VERY IN
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO DEFINES
CUTTER CREDIT RECOVERY AND
STATUTES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
VOTES.
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRD VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALENT VOTE AYE SIXTY NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY THREE AB ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL LEVIN TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALTH DATA.
BASE OR WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO AUTHORIZES THE COUNTY OF
INTEREST TO CONDUCT A PILOT
PROGRAM TO PREDICT WHICH MEDI
CAL RECIPIENTS ARE LIKELY TO
BECOME SUPER USERS.
OF EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES IN
RHODE ISLAND THE PROJECT WAS
ABLE TO IDENTIFY THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITH 8090% ACCURACY
AND WAS ABLE TO REDUCE THE COST
FOR IDENTIFYING THE TOP FIVE
HUNDRED USERS BY NEARLY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION.
IF THIS PREDICTIVE MODELING CAN
BE REPLICATED IN VENTURA COUNTY
IT CAN BE SURE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE POTENTIALLY SAVING
MILLIONS OF VALUABLE MEDI CAL
FUNDS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
GO.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THEIR TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY FOUR ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN TWENTY EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY INTO THE ELDERLY.
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THE PURPOSE
OF THIS BILL IS TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO PACE THE PROGRAM FOR ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE OUT
ELDERLY.
PACE IS A PROVEN AND EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS OUR SENIORS
TO AGE IN PLACE AND STAY IN
THEIR HOMES INSTEAD OF
INSTITUTIONS BUT WE HAVE A
CRITICAL SHORTAGE.
OF THE PACE AVAILABILITY ACROSS
THE STATE WERE EXPLORING A
NUMBER OF AVENUES TO ADDRESS
THAT AND THE SIX IN THIS BILL IS
PRIMARILY ADMINISTRATIVE -- WE
WILL BE CONSOLIDATING LICENSURE
FUNCTIONS WITH IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
IN ORDER TO STREAMLINE THE
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR PACE AND
ENABLE US TO BRING MORE AT THESE
FACILITIES ONLINE. TO HELP OUR
SENIORS AND HELP THEM AGE IN
PLACE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'VE IT THANK YOU MS BETWEEN OUR
AS SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY ONE KNOWS YEAR THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM ONE FORTY FIVE AB
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
VOTES.
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY TWO
KNOWS NINETEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
A PASS TEMPORARILY AND VIOLATE
ONE SIXTY FIVE VIOLATE ONE SIXTY
SIX AB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN THIRTY ONE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
MR GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
CHRONIC DISEASES EXPENSIVE IN
PATIENTS WITH CHRONIC DISEASE
UTILIZED DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES CHRONIC
DISEASES RISK ACCOUNTS 476% OF
ALL POSITION VISITS 81% OF A
HOSPITAL VISITS AND 91% OF ALL
PRESCRIPTIONS FILLED.
MANY PATIENTS ESPECIALLY THOSE
ACROSS MULTIPLE CHRONIC DISEASES
DO NOT REACH CLINICAL GOALS OF
THERAPY DUE TO SUB OPTIMAL
MEDICATION USE THIS BILL WILL
HELP IMPROVE OUTCOMES BY
PROVIDING GREATER.
COORDINATION OF THE MEDICATIONS
TAKEN BY THE STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE AND MOST ILL
POPULATIONS IN THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE RURAL AND
TALLIED VOTE I SIXTY SIX NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SEVEN AB
ELEVEN THIRTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
THREE BY SELLING MEMBER LOW AND
ACTON ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES SIR
LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FASTER CAN MEMBERS I OR DRIVE
OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER LO SI HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR VOTES.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE ONE SIXTY EIGHTY BE
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WOULD ACTUALLY MEDI CAL MISTER
WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
MAKE SEVERAL CHANGES TO IMPROVE
HOW THE MEDI CAL MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM FUNCTIONS BY INCREASING
THE AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
AVAILABLE ABOUT THE SYSTEM.
ESTABLISHING TIMELINES FOR
DISPUTE RESOLUTION AND CODIFYING
CONTINUITY OF CARE REQUIREMENTS
FOR PEOPLE WHOSE CONDITION
CHANGES.
SO THEY HAVE TO CHANGE FROM ONE
PLAN TO THE OTHER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WOODS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY SEVEN NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN EIGHTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC RECORDS SIR
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
RETAIN PUBLIC RECORDS THAT ARE
TRANSMITTED ELECTRONICALLY FOR
AT LEAST TWO YEARS THIS WILL
CLARIFY EXISTING PUBLIC RECORD
RETENTION LAW AND BRING IT INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE SUCH.
HOME MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO COACH.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLIED VOTE ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS FOR THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY AB TWELVE
OH TO THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO AND ACTUALLY
PRIVACY.
SEARCH HOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWELVE A TWO
IS A BILL TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE
THAT.
IMPACTS ALMOST EVERY CONSUMER IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS THE BUYING
AND SELLING OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT OR CCPA ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS
TO MONITOR AND CONTROL HOW THE
DATA IS USED SOLD OR OTHERWISE
EXCHANGED.
HOWEVER MANY CONSUMERS DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT BUSINESSES ARE
HOLDING THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
AB TWELVE OH TWO WILL REQUIRE A
DATA BROKERS DEFINED AS
BUSINESSES THAT BY AND OR SELL
PERSONAL DATA OF CONSUMERS WITH
WHOM THEY HAVE NO DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP. TO REGISTER WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
THE BILL WILL EMPOWER CONSUMERS
TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THE SEA CPA AND TO CONTROL THE
DATA WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAO SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESERTED VOTERS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
VOTES.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY KNOWS --
TWELVE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW ENTERTAIN.
THE SPEAKER PRO TEM THIS.
BILLS SO WE WILL BE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM.
FIFTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY TWO
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY CHILD CARE.
SIR MILLING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU FOR THAT GAVEL MADAM
SPEAKER.
AB FOR FIFTY TWO SEEKS TO
CONVERT THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
CARE FACILITIES REVOLVING FUND
INTO THE CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE
FACILITIES GRANT FUND.
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING AN
ECONOMIC BOOM YEAH MOST FAMILIES
ARE UNABLE TO FIND LICENSE CARE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN WHILE THEY
WORK FOR THE FEW AVAILABLE
INFINITE TALLER SPOTS.
CARE IS PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE.
AB FOR FIFTY TWO WILL PROVIDE
GRANTS TO BILL CHILD CARE
CENTERS AND MAKE MINOR
MODIFICATIONS TO CHILD CARE
HOMES FOR EXPANSION OR TO MEET
SAFETY STANDARDS PRIORITY WILL
GO TO CENTER SERVING INFANTS AND
TODDLERS.
CHILDREN WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS
AND THOSE WHO HAVE SUFFERED A
DISASTER.
GRANT FUNDS TO BUILD SHOCKER
FACILITIES AND EXPAND CAPACITY
WILL KEEP COSTS LOW TORTURE CARE
IS AFFORDABLE FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO MISTER MCCARTY. FOR
HIS PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT ON
THE ISSUE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE [inaudible]
ALL.
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE CASH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES WIENER FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TWO AB SEVEN THIRTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN THIRTEEN BY
SOME MEMBER MULLIN AND ACTUALLY
MENTAL HEALTH.
MR MULLIN.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB SEVEN THIRTEEN AS A
FOLLOW UP MEASURE TO A BILL I
AUTHORED LAST SESSION A. B..
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN WHICH ESTABLISH
THE EARLY PSYCHOSIS DETECTION
AND INTERVENTION FINE. TO GRANT
COUNTIES FUNDING TO PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO RESIDENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
THE BILL WOULD SIMPLY REMOVE THE
ORIGINAL REQUIREMENT THAT NON
STATE FUNDS BE DEPOSITED INTO
THE FIND BEFORE THE PROGRAM IS
IMPLEMENTED ENSURING THAT THE
COMMISSION CAN BEGIN ALLOCATING
RESOURCES FOR THE PURPOSES.
OF EARLY PSYCHOSIS DETECTION WE
KNOW THAT A PROGRAM OF THIS SORT
IS SORELY NEEDED 50% OF ALL
MENTAL ILLNESS BEGINS BY THE AGE
OF FOURTEEN AND 75% BY THE AGE
OF TWENTY FOUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
OFTEN RELUCTANT AND AFRAID TO
SEEK HELP.
IF SUCH CONDITIONS GO UNTREATED
A PERSON'S RISK FOR SUICIDE
INVOLUNTARY EMERGENCY CARE AND
DISABILITY LATER IN ADULTHOOD IS
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED AB SEVEN
THIRTEEN WOULD HELP DELIVER MUCH
NEEDED RESOURCES TO COUNTY SO
THAT THEY ARE BETTER EQUIPPED.
TO PROVIDE EARLY PSYCHOSIS
ATTENTION SERVICES SHIFTING AWAY
FROM THE STANDARD OF REACTIONARY
CARE THAT MANY RECEIVED ONCE
THEIR CONDITIONS HAVE SEVERELY
PROGRESS.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THERE WAS NO CHIME BUT
WE'RE VOTE AND ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESERTED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE SUCH.
I KNOW YOU RESPOND TO THE TIME
BUT WE ARE VOTING ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTES BEING.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ONE
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING TO A FILE ITEM.
TWO OH SEVEN AB SEVEN FORTY BY
MISS BURKE THE CLERK WILL READ.
A SIMPLE SEVEN FORTY WITH THE
MEMONS MY FAMILY MEMBER BURKE
THIS BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS -- MOMENTS JUST
EIGHTY SEVEN FOR YOU CHANGE THE
NAME OF THE ESTABLISHMENT AND
ADDS CO AUTHORS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE AMENDMENT BE
ADOPTED AND THEY'LL BE PUT OUT
TO PRINT AND PLACED BACK ON THE
FILE.
THANK YOU MISS BURKE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES
HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
OUT TO PRINT BACK TO FILE.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY NINTH WHERE
FLOOR SESSION AT TEN AM.
THURSDAY MAY THIRTIETH FLOOR
SESSION AT TEN AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASS RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN [inaudible]
MISS.
HIS RUBIO MOVES MISTER FLORES
SECOND THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL WEDNESDAY MAY
TWENTY NINTH AT TEN AM.
FORM CALLS LIFTED
VOTE CHANGE
CALDERON ITEM SEVENTY TWO A. B.
SEVEN THIRTEEN NO TWO I THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN THIRTEEN
NOTES I'D
.
MURATSUCHI VOTE CHANGE FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY SIX A. B..
FOUR I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AS A LABEL FOR I TO
NOT VOTING
.
CERVANTES WROTE CHANGE AB.
FOUR NINE SEVEN I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES SOME PEOPLE FOR NINETY
SEVEN I IT'S NOT VOTING